e
good morning welcome to
Edna I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 192 and I'm going to call
Representative
Schmid he was here
well good representative Schmidt you're
up we are the prime sponsor of House
d
morning everyone you
did yes I open the hearing you opened
okay thank you so for the record Peter
Schmidt uh Stafford 19 I'm that's do
award one uh and I am the prime sponsor
as you see of
192 um I am a a member of the so-called
joint committee on employee
classification along with representative
scitec who was actually was on there
before I was but then it was off for
couple of um couple of years while he
was on uh criminal justice the statute
requires two members of Edna house Edna
and one member of House
fiscal uh there are three Senators I
think they're approximately in the same
configuration but uh it's a six person
committee and it's part of the uh part
of the is the title of the committee
joint committee on employee
classification it was uh established
about 30 years ago I think uh before my
time but but the idea of it was to keep
the two parties from wrangling over
employee classification and getting into
you know as I say wrangling which is uh
uh deemed to be counterproductive and I
think it uh has worked well in terms of
getting that out of uh the legislator
legislator hair um but because the
executive department has to hire people
they and they they have a classification
SE uh
system uh so low ranking employees might
be a double a uh or double b or
something like that or just one a or one
B uh and it goes right up to I don't
know like FF John higher than that
higher GG um in any case
and the legislature employs A A
specialized company out in San Francisco
I think called corn fairy hay uh and
their job is to um monitor the market
see what uh What uh rates are across the
country and so forth and make
recommendations to us so if a if a
department comes to us with a particular
hire that they want to make or somebody
they want to promote or they want to
change their classification in any way
they give us the the the
jce uh a series of questionnaires that
they would put out there to find out
what people might uh uh offer for
qualifications to have such a job and
that the agency comes up with a
particular proposed rating then that
comes to the
jce for First Step which is what we we
recommend that it go to Corn fairy hay
that's a procedural thing um and then
corn fairy hay will come back at some
point with their recommendation for what
that for what that classification would
be then the court the the
jcec is the
executive agency if you will that that
approves
that um uh and after that then it comes
here for it to be put into the statute
then it goes to fiscal which is why we
have members of JC and fiscal from the
house on that it goes to fiscal for
being put in the
budget and then if that it gets approved
at that point then that person can be
either promoted or hired or whatever at
that classification so the the the jcec
is what's called a ministerial committee
we are the executive um and uh and then
comes here for for the next step so this
bill is the
recommendation um if you if you open it
up and look at it you'll see a whole
series of things that have already been
to the
jcec they've already been approved and
now um it's Edna's call to carry out the
next step any questions about how that
works
okay so in any case uh I not only do I
have this bill
192 um but I also have an amendment has
that been passed out to all of you no
it okay well let's get
hands so come and sit down please
because I need you here in case there
sorry yes ma'am please introduce
yourself um for the record my name is
Jane Graham I'm the Strategic
Communications administrator for the
Department of
Corrections Department of what
correction Corrections oh okay thank you
okay oh there's the commissioner lurking
in the background in case we have any
real questions okay any this is
commissioner Helen Hanks of the
department of Corrections for those of
you who don't know her and for those of
you who do that's who she is anyway so
there was an error made at the last JCC
meeting where as I understand it well
why don't you tell us Jam because you're
the one that you told me and I don't
want to have them have to hear it from
me when you're the one okay we have one
position our deputy director of Medical
Services that's already gone through JC
on the September agenda that was left
out of this bill so so um we are asking
for please an amendment to add this
position that's already gone through the
jcec process to this piece of
legislation and this was just omitted it
was just omitted yeah it yes it's
already gone through that
process so this this position that
you're asking for in the amendment that
is still not
here this is a letter from cour fa which
is back up to the amendment so where is
the amendment I don't have an amendment
what I don't have an amendment but I can
I'm happy to representative Schmidt uh
they can't I don't believe the
Department of Corrections can get an
amendment that's something that you'll
have to do this is just informing this
is useful information and back up to the
amendment that you're going to get at
your earliest convenience
okay so this
is so are there any questions from the
committee on what we're doing here joh
if you're not thoroughly confused you're
not paying attention representative
shitech in fact the amendment is that
line you're going to insert that in the
list of positions that are in the Bill
that's right that's all that the
amendment's going to do right just adds
that o overlooked item I might mention
that at JCC meetings I was I've been on
it for quite some time actually and we
actually had two senators come once oh
two senators at the same meeting well
it's a six it's a six p uh person
committee three from each chamber but
obviously if all three de if all three
delegates or designes are there from the
house uh that's only three people we
need one Senator or vice versa some
mixture of four and if the Senators
don't come then we only have three three
house members that's not a quorum so it
is a problem getting a quorum which is
why I'm grateful that representative
scitec was reappointed because he knows
the drill and and it can be a little
confusing the first time around and if I
have you all thoroughly confused then we
can proceed are there any
questions okay very good well thank
you representative
broa so I just want to be clear as to
what the amendment is going to it it
apparently it's on this letter from corn
Fair and which
line I just want to make sure that I
understand which line we're
adding or we're
amending it would be adding a new a new
line I
believe is there Corrections this is
GG okay the the there's already a deputy
director of rehabilitative services on
line 25 and this would presumably add
another department of corrections deputy
okay so the JCC generally uh kind of
rubber stamps what the corn fairy hay
recommends usually the the the agency
and the corn fairy will agree but if
corn faery says it should be higher or
lower then it's up to us the JCC which
one we're going to go with we generally
agree with them that's they're the
experts that's why we hire them and pay
them so they give us the the the most
likely correct rating or classification
and we rubber stamp it then it comes
here thank you are represent got a
comment except for the coroner that we
bumped higher than corn FY because of
shortage well the the rating was was may
have been Market correct but it turns
the agency was looking around uh for
that person they couldn't get anybody to
respond because the rating was too low
for this area so we approved a higher
salary because otherwise we weren't
going to get anybody for that corner
questions on uh thank you madam chair um
with this role of the um deputy director
of medical services within the
Department of Corrections is that
currently in the section where that
position would be deleted from the
current listing and then added to the
second or is it just adding to the
second it I don't know sorry
commissioner I just want to make sure we
do this correctly when we get the
it's good morning for the record my name
is Helen Hanks I'm the commissioner of
the Department of Corrections I
apologize it took me a bit to find a
place to park um appreciate
representative Schmidt we identified
this was a position that went through
the jcec process but wasn't included in
the bill and we're hopeful that an
amendment will come forward to your uh
question it's a new unclassified
position it is an existing classified
position and so we'll extinguish the
classified and retain the unclassified
so we didn't add a position we changed
its classification status thank you
you're
welcome and simply by adding that
position to this list that will
accomplish shouldn't we abolish the
existing uh existing classified position
uh thank you madam chair when we put
this through hb2 that language was
already included in the ask to go from
classified to unclassified to abolish it
was that in hb2 this year or two years
ago two years ago Ma
thank you I'm glad to know it's been
taken care of you're
welcome
okay any other comments questions
issues thank you is there thank you for
being here commissioner thank you is
there anyone else who needs to who
wishes to testify on House Bill
192 all right seeing none thank you I'm
going to close the public hearing
representative Schmidt you are uh going
hope thank
you uh we have one minute and I'm
co-sponsor the next one so you're in
charge
thank you seeing that it is 10:15 I will
open the public hearing on House Bill
435 and call the prime sponsor Donal
McFarland and if we can get a pink card
when you get a chance oh we have one
from him ready yes we do I'm sorry I I
when I walked in I heard you saying
something about health and human
services and I said wait a second I'm in
the right room um but you do have a pink
card sorry oh and sorry can we change
the sign as well one moment I think I
go thank you new system and I appreciate
that all right well hopefully the uh the
rest of my testimony will be equally
helpful uh good morning uh Mr chairman
honorable members I'm representative Don
McFarland from Orange and I thank you
for the opportunity to Produce House
Bill
435 this testimony represents My Views
and the views and interests of my
constituents in graft and 18 my
testimony is not made on behalf of any
private employer nor should it be
construed to represent the views of any
of my employers I come before you today
to introduce and voice my strong support
for House Bill 435 which seeks simply to
clean up and clarify our professional
licensure statutes with regard to the
field of licensed professional
engineering uh and ensure that they
accurately reflect current practice HB
435 clarifies that professionals working
in the fields of it it security
Electronics digital systems and
Computing are not engaged in the
practice of engineering as defined in
state law while these fields are highly
technical they do not require license
you as a professional engineer nor have
they ever in practice been regulated
that way however as the law is currently
written there remains ambiguity that
suggests they could be which creates
legal uncertainty and unnecessary risk
for professionals working in these
fields the bill does not deregulate
engineering instead it simply ensures
that our laws match reality that is the
work being done in it cyber security and
digital systems today is not uh
something where you see a material
number of license pees nor are they
required to put a seal on their work by
passing HP 435 we eliminate this gray
area we provide regulatory Clarity and
we ensure that New Hampshire remains a
state that supports technological
innovation without unnecessary
bureaucratic
overreach in preparing this bill uh even
before it had been drafted by
OLS I spoke with uh at least one of
the um the the organizations that uh
comes before the state house and
advocates for for the uh the practce of
Engineering in the state the American
Council of engineering
companies and I engaged in a number of
phone calls with them I engaged in a
zoom core with uh several of their
representatives uh most of whom were uh
Engineers pees
themselves and while we did not arrive
at a common understanding on chosen
language uh nevertheless what I
understood clearly from them is that
their interest is limited to to the
circumstances where Engineers are
required to provide sealed documents in
support of uh the you know raft of good
reasons that this committee well
understands that those are already
required today uh especially for for
Fields such as the Building Trades um
and civil engineering and structural
engineering and so forth and so uh I'm
happy to dive in on this as as the
committee sees fit I didn't want to over
complicate the issue and I urge the
committee to support this Common Sense
Bill and move it forward so thank you
for your time and I'm happy to yield to
any questions thank you are there any
questions from the committee
representative
Bailey thank you I am not one but I have
encountered people in the past that were
electronic Engineers or had degrees and
such and they would seem to be
excluded so I I can tell you that I am
one
such um and in writing this bill WR you
know drafting the language for this bill
I wanted to strike a reasonable balance
between excluding the fields where we
know that this is just not something
that that is required in practice uh and
not excluding too broad uh of a set of
of disciplines to the point where I I
felt it was going to you know create too
much strife and disagreement uh and I'm
sure that there will be some people who
want to speak in opposition it was
interesting to me I checked a few
moments ago online for the online
testimony and there's a handful of of uh
folks have submitted testimony there one
is um of the three people that have
written some some textual responses one
is neutral one is in opposition one is
supportive and it was interesting to me
to note that the individual who
supported this describes themselves as
an engineer and as somebody with that
kind of a background and the person who
was opposed uh is clearly coming at it
as uh that this is somehow intended to
disenfranchise uh electronic Engineers
Information Technology uh professionals
and so forth and and lower their
salaries and I can tell you as somebody
who has spent um multiple decades and
essentially all of my working life
working in these types of fields I have
no interest in doing
that thank you thank you other questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much represent than is there anybody
bill seeing none uh we will close the
hearing on House Bill 435 thank you our
next bill is scheduled at
10:30 but I will hand the gavel back
is there anyone who does not think we
should go into executive
session all right seeing none in that
case as a
sponsor I will move out to pass on House
Bill
435 and I will second
I'll just say that it's it's common it
it seems to me to be a very common sense
exclusion because most software
Engineers do not do the sort of things
that we require a professional
engineer's license for um I've worked in
engineering my entire career and the
types of engineers who get licensed are
structural or civil engineers or
mechanical engineers working on various
types of
Machinery that have safety
constraints of software for some reason
is not normally included and the test to
become a licensed Engineers don't deal
with software they deal with structures
and
mechanics at least at least they did
when I was considering taking them and I
don't believe it's been added since then
so I think that this
is clarifying what
people are already
doing representative excuse me
representative
Howard thank you my significant other is
currently in the process of getting her
professional engineering license and I I
had her look over this and she felt that
it was completely fine she's getting uh
her uh Masters in environmental
engineering and this does not affect
environmental engineering civil
engineering uh or any of the actual
practicing engineering that require PE
like you said so uh for that reason I'm
going to be supporting the Bill thank
you representative Lon uh thank you
madam chair um I support this bill
because when I was going through school
and was surrounded by Engineers I was
trying to understand this whole
licensing for some engineers and not and
essentially it comes down to the
Professional Engineers or kind of the
physical engineers they're involved in
physical things that are out there in
the world and not the software the
things that could fall down on you or
could break physically um and so I think
that this is just a common sense
clarification of our statutes okay
anyone else representative Bailey I
guess I'm still trying to understand I'm
I'm thinking of somebody I went to high
school with so you could imagine it was
long ago went to Wentworth in Boston and
was an electronic engineer was the
degree and worked for many years for
deck building physical computer
ERS um would this exclude him Assuming
he's still working you
know um somebody in that category it was
probably probably yes representative SL
is that fair then why he doesn't need it
he's working it's not software it's
Electronics he was working on a physical
computer yes thank you thank you so um
we seem to have a lot of engineers in
the room I'm a chemical engineer and um
professional engineering
licenses are something that you need in
a certain type of engineering Li for
example Professional Engineers who have
a license as a professional engineer
it's a PE
license um often times have to certify
plans and they use a seal that they
obtain from the
um
profession electronic Engineers when
they build computers do not need that
seal so it's just um and neither do
chemical Engineers when they build
chemical plants because all we do is the
schematic of the equations we actually
don't build the facility mechanical
engineers do and then they need that
seal so it has nothing to do with
letting people do work or any type of of
um status in profession it simply is a
function of the job that they're doing
it's like an architect who builds who
who puts together an architectural plan
has a seal on that plan that says that
they're a certified architect it's the
same type of thing it has nothing to do
with how great you are at your job or um
you know how proficient you are in a
particular feel it is simply a function
of the it's requirement of the role does
that help you thank you no
repri yeah just had additional context I
used to work in uh highly regulated
software development um was never
required to maintain a license or
require a license um essentially the
safety factors are all brought down to
the work product so any concerns about
uh safety in that regulated space is
much more focused on uh process and
development output um rather than the
engineers
themselves yes and I will say that as a
mechanical engineer working in
Aerospace I never needed a license or
even after looking at it decided I would
get one but for for example my
brother-in-law was the chief engineer of
the compressor department and he had to
have a license because he was signing
off the final drawings the people that
worked for him would develop the designs
under his guidance and then he would
sign off the final drawing and that's
the way it works for large organizations
smaller organizations if you're going to
be in business for yourself you need to
have the license because there's nobody
else to do it representative Pearson so
it's uh it's always extraordinary to see
the culmination of brain power in a room
my my engineering technology degree is
in fire protection
which is a little bit different in the
sense of the the physical although there
you know we do um we
do create plans that plumbers put
together in some in some cases but um I
I just I don't want
the uh I don't want there to be
confusion between electrical engineers
and electronics for those of you that
are reading that thinking that they're
the same thing because they are most
definitely not so um electrical
engineers
are much different in what they do um in
a in practice so so just to just to Cal
fears on on that one term that that is
uh they are not equivalent in any
way yes elect electrical engineers deal
with things like power lines and
Transformer stations and I believe those
have to
be approved and and reviewed by a
professional engineer a piece of
but most uh most most people working in
software or Electronics would have no
clue what to do with designing a uh
station all right any other questions
comments
issues all right in that case a motion
is ought to pass and the clerk can call
La
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey yes
representative Shen
yes representative sers
yes representative yes
representative EO yes representative
groden yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes
yes representative Heath
yes representative stes yes
representative long yes the chair yes 16
for the record that would be
representative
Howard didn't I say that you call him
did I do it
again I I didn't he the first time you
confusion having two first name it's the
curse of having a first name as a last
name
yes all right so um the mo the motion
passes 16 to zero is there any objection
to
consent all right seeing none we'll put
that on consent
and and I will uh write a report at my
earliest
convenience all
right opening the hearing on House Bill
210 and I'm
thank you madam chair good morning
Edna I am Tom Corman from what I like to
call the fight in 15th Grafton 15 which
is Ward three of the fair city of
Lebanon here to talk about hb21 about
state flags uh there's a handout going
around uh called good flag bad flag with
principles of flag design we will talk
about it but first I'm going to show you
a bunch of state
flags here are 25 state flags you notice
that they're all pretty similar uh I've
crossed out a couple I'll talk about
those for a sec ours is somewhere in
here um good luck finding it it's uh
where it's uh right here on the uh
middle row but it's one of many state
flags that uh many of which are called a
state seal on a blue bed sheet ours is
one of them
and I've crossed out a couple of them
I've crossed out this one and then this
one because those have been changed
those are from states that actually
decided that their flags were not unique
and didn't look uh didn't represent
their states so we like to think of New
Hampshire as unique I mean I've heard it
many times on the floor of the house but
our flag is anything but unique and it
fails to convey that New Hampshire is
unique now there are other states that
have much more distinctive
Flags okay and you can see many of them
here um uh for example New Mexico uh
which is this one is considered a very
good one everyone knows Texas with the
Lone Star Arizona with the
sunrise and let's see Ohio which is the
pennant
down here and Maryland the Calbert cross
flag for Maryland and then the two
states that actually changed their Flags
Utah which changed their flag to
represent a beehive which and Utah being
the Beehive State and some Mountains and
the most recent one Minnesota this is
the new Minnesota flag which actually
has essentially the shape of Minnesota
in the flag so there are states that
have been changing their flag
designs so the New Hampshire flag
violates the vexillological principles
vexillology is of course the study of
flags as we all know and the New
Hampshire flag violates the principles
that are in the handout that you have so
let's look at the New Hampshire
flag I hope you can see this you've all
seen the New Hampshire flag before right
the state seal on on a blue bed
sheet so if you look at the handout it
has these principles number one keep it
simple so simple that a child can draw
it from memory a single simple large
shapes the flag should be recognizable
from a
distance well you know if you had this
flag with a bunch of the other flags and
a hall of flags such as at the US
capital it would be hard to pick out the
New Hampshire flag and in terms of uh
that a child could draw it from memory
all right take a typical eight-year-old
and ask them to draw this and imagine
what you're going to get so we fail on
that account number two use meaningful
symbolism images colors and patterns
should relate to what the flag
symbolizes for a symbol consider history
cultural heritage emotional value
branding usage and stylized or
silhouetted symbols are better than
realistic
depictions so what do we have have on
the New Hampshire flag we have the
symbol on the state seal the boat known
as the
Raleigh what percentage of granite sters
could tell you the first thing about the
boat on the New Hampshire flag school
kids May learn something about it um I
didn't go to school in New Hampshire so
I didn't learn anything about the boat I
didn't even know the name of it until a
couple of years ago and um it wasn't
built in New Hampshire it was built in
Maine and apparently during the
Revolutionary War it was captured by the
British and used against the colonists
so that's not so great and by the way if
you look in the in the state seal it's
on
land so it's not even a boat in the
water it's a boat on land so I'm not
advocating to change the state seal
although I think it's not a bad idea
just not to use it on the
flag next principle use two or three
basic colors and the basic flag colors
are red blue green black yellow or white
but don't use all of them use two or
three of them and separate the dark
colors by the light and the light colors
by the dark for contrast if you have
more than four colors it makes the flag
hard to distinguish and hard to
reproduce so I actually counted the
colors we have we have eight we have
dark blue gold green red light blue
brown black and white so eight colors on
our flag and then of course no lettering
or seals well we have the seal and we
also have the lettering that says um uh
seal of the state of New Hampshire so
words defeat the purpose a flag is a
graphic symbol lettering is hard to read
from a distance I mean you certainly
can't read the lettering on our flag
unless you're right up against the flag
seals are designed to be read at close
range so enough said for this flag and
finally be distinctive or be related
avoid duplicating other flags but use
similari to show connections well we
don't duplicate other flags but the
state seal on a blue bed sheet design is
the opposite of
distinctive um on the very last page of
the handout I have uh at the bottom
YouTube does your flag fail so I
encourage you go to YouTube Type in
those words does your flag fail and
it'll take you to about an 18-minute
very entertaining video about state
flags and um showing that ours is among
those that get a failing
grade so this
Bill establishes a commission to study
the New Hampshire flag it's got three
house members one Senator and unlike any
other flag bill that I've seen and I had
OS do research for me this one has two
other people it has the president of the
New Hampshire Historical Society or
their designate and the head of the New
England vexillological Association or
their
designate no previous FL uh flag Bill
had anybody from either the Historical
Society or a vexal
vexillologist I can't say it this
commission would be unique it would
review the history of the flag it would
examine the vexillological principles
and it would recommend whether to
redesign the flag and if so a process to
create the proposed design the
commission may propose its own design
but it's not required to do so it may
recommend an implementation schedule for
the design now there's one thing that I
intend to have in the bill but uh
apparently OS dropped it but I'd like it
to to be in there at some point which is
that I I don't want this to cost the
state money I mean we have a lot of
flags that the state owns and if we were
to change the flag design that would be
a lot of new flags that we'd have to buy
so what I'd recommend would be that uh
and what I wanted in the bill was that
if the flag design does change new Flags
would be the new design old Flags would
not have to be
replaced until they actually wore out so
that there would be no additional cost
it would just be when we buy new Flags
we buy the new flag so that's the bill
um I know that we've seen a lot of flag
bills over the years I know we had one
last year I remember testifying against
it because what it did was it added
lettering to the flag and I know uh that
you're going to hear a flag bill this
afternoon uh I just think that this is
the process to go through to actually
have a commission with informed people
on it to decide what we might want to do
with our non-unique state flag and with
that I'm happy to take
questions represento thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question so I visited Utah a
couple of times I love their new state
flag it's great but um on on state
buildings they still fly the old state
flag as a symbol of their history um
would you support flying both state
flags on state buildings or just the new
one and with or with this commission
would this be something where we would
be required to adopt the um commission's
report or would it be um up to the
legislature to determine if it wants to
accept the results or not thank you uh
as far as flying two flags that's really
up to the state and and up to the
administration of the state what they'd
want to do um and then uh I'm sorry what
was the second question
um would the legislature be required to
adop right yes yeah um and I would
expect that that this commission would
recommend legislation which is typically
what a commission or committee would do
legislation yes and in fact as written
the commission would issue a report and
if they did recommend a flag it would
require future legislation which would
include the transition language that's
necessary Neary to make sure we don't
have to replace every single flag in in
in the State
representam uh thank you madam chair and
thank you representative for bringing
this to us uh looking at what you
provided here it sounds like there'll be
a committee looking at how to redesign
the flag however on the last page of the
document you gave us it said don't allow
a committee to design a flag instead
import power individuals to design flags
and use a committee to select among them
I'm just curious how I recognize that
this is something that people have been
working on for a long time and I'm just
trying to understand how creating a
commission solves that problem of not
having a committee design the flag thank
you uh so the bill says that the
commission would recommend a process and
the process might be hire an actual
vexal I can't a person you know the
vexillological person um to design the
flag or it might say uh let's get uh a
couple of people from the logical
Association but the point is that the
the commission would design a process
which might include the commission
not other
questions thank you all right thank
thank you madam chair friends and
colleagues on the House Executive
Department's Administration committee I
think representative Corman did a
fantastic job as to why this study
committee wouldn't be important I just
would like to add my support to the
study committee uh understanding the
effort to get rid of study committees
and commissions I think this is one that
meets the standards that have been set
by the people who are trying to get rid
of those study commissions and committ
uh committees and commissions that
standard being interest in the committee
and representatives showing that they
would actually serve on the committee
and want to do this work diligently I
know for a fact that there are
Representatives would want to serve on
this committee and do that work uh which
to me means that this is a good enough
committee to want to approve and as
representative Corman
outlaid our flag is not unique it's a
very un unique flag flag and for such a
unique State you'd think we'd want a
distinct flag that shows our character
respects our Traditions to your point
representative tibio you know maybe it'd
be good to have the flag flying but I
don't think there's many people in New
Hampshire who view the flag as a
connecting piece to our to our history I
think in fact given the fact that the
boat is built in M was built in Maine
captured by the British and used against
American soldiers during the revolution
ution it's actually kind of a a bit of a
spitting on on New Hampshire tradition
and history when there are so many other
stories of people like General John
Stark and Daniel Webster I know you had
legislation earlier today to honor him
that would be so much more significant
to have on our flag and represent as the
history and tradition of the State of
New Hampshire and I think the
opportunity that we have here with this
commission is to create a new flag not
by designed by the commission as
representative Corman said but to open
up the process by which that design
would happen so that maybe a design
which connects to our history and makes
people want to look into it a little bit
more comes about so I'm just here to
support Vex olical standards and thank
representative Corman for bringing this
bill forward and I hope you know it's
changing the flag shouldn't be the
legislator's priority but being a
legislator means that you can focus on a
million and one different things at the
same time okay and I think that this is
one of those things where you know it
doesn't have to be our Focus but it can
be something that we can start to move
the ball forward on because our flag is
not unique and uh the
blue tarp that it is is just not
respectful I think of the distinct
nature of the State of New Hampshire so
with that thank you very much Madam
chair I I wouldn't expect there to be
questions questions yes thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thank you
representative wheeler and I apologize
to representative Corman I probably
should have asked this question of you
um but it there's a common saying about
um a camel is a horse designed by
committee I think that I agree with
representative Leon of regarding the
power of this commission uh to
design a state flag um on lines 25 and
26 it says the commission shall have the
ability to propose one or more of its
own designs but is not required to do so
um would you and the prime sponsor be
open given that there may be an
amendment coming uh to removing that
piece of it so that we don't get a
design coming out of this committee but
only a recommendation regarding process
I think it's thank you I thank you
representative D um you know study
committees and their their charges I
have other study committee legislation
around school start times and uh we are
going back and forth about the exact
language around the charge of the
committee I I always find it a little
bit funny if the committee determines
that the language in 25 and 26 is such
that uh it would prompt the committee to
create a design it's not how I read it
but if that's how the committee views it
then I would be fine with removing that
language and making explicitly the
committee's duty to have it be such that
they create the process by which we
design the flag thank you thank you are
there any other questions representative
Schmidt thank you madam chairman so so
do you think representative that the
average citizen of New Hampshire has any
idea how how boring and uh
and typical our flag is of bad flag
design that in other words we see we
know our own flag but we don't know
other flags so we don't
realize how much it is a bad design
representative Schmidt i' would say I
think they do the people who have come
up to me and said I heard that you're on
legislation to change the state flag
they've been very excited about it
because they see the flag as
extraordinarily boring and they've heard
the stories of what's happened in Utah
and Minnesota how states are moving
forward to change this flag and uh yeah
people as far as I've seen as far as my
personal anecdote can relay have been
very uh excited about the prospect that
we'd get a flag that respects the
traditions of the State of New Hampshire
thank you thank you
anyone
else thank you representative we thank
you madam
morning
the hello I
I think that the state flag should be
changed and I have a bill which is
actually going to be heard later today
on that same subject but I don't think
there should be a
commission uh in Massachusetts there was
a commission to change the state flag
the first time it failed to come up with
a design and then the commission had to
ask for another extension and another
$100,000
and now in
2024 they got another
$100,000 to restart the commission
because it ended up even after the
extension not coming up with a design
and now it's getting another
100,000 for a new commission to come up
with a design again and I also think
that um New Hampshire has 138 statutory
commissions we even have a committee to
get rid of commissions and uh last
session one of my sponsors was vice
chair of that committee so I think I
support changing the state flag I just
don't think we need a committee to do
that thank you very much I happen to
agree with you other uh questions
comments represent yeah I have a
question for my friend here um can you
say your name again in what town you're
from Andrew
Milfred represent tuba thank you for
being here I just wanted to say it's
always great to see young people getting
involved and I think your testimony was
excellent so thanks for being here thank
you anyone
else all right thank you for your
testimony you're welcome is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on House Bill
all right seeing none I will close the
public
hearing
anyone represent
Fellers yeah Madam chair if you're
asking about this bill here going to
exective session I would hold off for
right now I think there's I like to
discuss it more internally
and okay well
that's fine we don't like to execute
unless it's obvious and it seems like it
isn't all right in that case we have uh
left this the inite
scho he's home
a
e
yes sir um the prime sponsor of this
bill is currently down the hall for a
minute
taking care of something and she will be
right
back uh fine if you would introduce the
bill on her behalf I would appreciate it
you don't not have to speak in favor of
how slow can you
it it's not the years it's the
mileage got a lot of tough miles here
okay
so this is
the house build
52 the prime sponsor representative Reed
will be here very
shortly this bill clarifies the effect
of designated A Day a legal holiday and
make the days on which the state primary
quadral no I'm I'm just actually reading
the analysis for the
committee thank you representative
Pearson for your efforts on the
committee's behalf
representative
Reed sorry we started a bit
late thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee um
for the record my name is Ellen Reed I
represent Rockingham 10 which is New
Market and
newfields HB 52 although it says an act
relative to legal holidays is um
actually election day holiday it's
election day holiday bill um I will get
into the mechanics of why why it's
worded what how it is worded um which
kind of was a an interesting process to
get there but um I will start with why
our elections are held on Tuesday when
that federal law was passed and the
federal um Congress has dictated the day
of our federal elections obviously um we
were a very agrarian society we didn't
have most people working N9 to five jobs
and uh most people went to church and so
Tuesday was considered to be
the most convenient day because people
would go to church on Sunday they'd have
a day of travel and then could uh vote
they'd have to travel to their voting
location they would vote on Tuesday so
it's been Tuesday for a very long time
and now Tuesday is very inconvenient for
most of um society and
um the the obvious advantage to having
an election day holiday is isn't this
great a lot of workers would be able
more able to go to the polling places um
and I'm imagining bringing their
children and and the whole bit but I
want to talk a lot more about the
cultural advantage of having an election
day holiday because it's not just the
logistics around increased availability
after all this would only apply to uh
government employees we can't mandate
that any uh business shuts down on
Election Day this certainly doesn't uh
claim to do that and most people work in
the private
sector um some businesses tend to follow
suit with state holidays but certainly
not everybody um it does there is the
last part of the bill that allows uh
employees of the private sector up to
three hours unpaid to go vote if they
are scheduled to work during polling
hours but the cultural importance of
having a
holiday that raises awareness and
celebrates the idea that we are a
democracy and let me just pause there
because I know that sometimes there's
controversy around the word democracy I
did teach American government at the
college level for a number of years um
sometimes there's confusion around the
word democracy versus republic Republic
is a flavor of democracy so we are a
democracy we are a rule by the people
democracy um there are two basic flavors
of democracy direct democracy which is
basically practiced in no government
anywhere because it's too um unwieldy
and a direct or a representative
democracy where we elect people which is
also known as a republic so when I say
democracy please understand that I'm
talking about our
Republic the cultural value of having a
day off to celebrate the fact that we
were an experiment in
democracy that we that was our whole
founding principle that we were getting
rid of kings and we were turning the
power over to the people the cultural
significance of that cannot be um
overstated we have a day off to
celebrate people who have fought for
this country for our democracy we have
another day off to celebrate people who
fought and then died for this country we
have a day off celebrating presidents of
this country and their birthdays and of
course we have a huge day off for the um
annual celebration of the birth of our
independence as a democracy
um these are things that we put on the
calendar we know we're coming we are
planning barbecues we're planning
fireworks we're planning events and
those ideas of those days whether it's
Memorial Day or fourth of July those
concepts are in our minds as we are
looking forward to that day off
together why are we celebrating all the
people who fought and died and served
for our democracy and not celebrating
the actual day we do the actual thing
that they fought and died and served for
I don't understand that but there is one
part of our vast country that does
actually have an actual in practice
election day holiday and that is Puerto
Rico Puerto Rico has the day off and
it's not just a you know we have time
off of work isn't this great we get to
go do this thing now they have parades
that they call caravanas it's a huge
cultural tradition steeped day of mock
debates or debates and mock elections
and just really celebrating the idea of
self-governance Puerto Rico's turnout is
in the high
90s we are no slouches in New Hampshire
we're third among states we're not
90 we're not close here's the one very
very interesting piece of that so they
you Puerto Ricans grow up in this
culture where they're celebrating this
and they have the day off when Puerto
Ricans move to the mainland same
country just a different
culture with
no day to celebrate that day their voter
turnout goes down to the 60% with the
average of the mainlanders so I'm not
content to be third in the nation for
turnout I believe in the principles of a
robust Republic where everyone gets a
voice and I think we all bemoan the fact
that our very own constituents don't
know who we are don't understand Civics
don't understand the principles of of
government and have kind of turn
themselves off and I think celebrating
that day is not just a logistical win
for people to be able to turn out but
it's a cultural win for people to be
re-engaged with their government so just
very briefly the mechanics when I said
uh originally eight years ago I would
like to add election day as a holiday
turns out election day is already listed
as our holiday we have a list of state
holidays we have no definition for what
that
means and I I set about with research
saying okay so what does it mean that we
have a list of state holidays because it
doesn't say what we do on state holidays
and it turns out election day is
basically in this list the only day that
we do not have a in practice legal
holiday so it's in the list of state
holidays but it's the only one in the
list where we don't have an actual legal
holiday for
it so I went about defining what we do
for all the other holidays and basically
it says if it's not and I hate to use
the word essential but essential
Services um that those people have the
day off and what we're talking about um
in terms of logistics is essentially a
snow day and I think our Republic is
worth a snow day I did include primary
so because if it was just election day
just the general election it would be
once every two years if you include
primary it's two days every two years so
it averages out to yearly um and
primaries are often where the real uh
democracy is is acted and um I included
primaries to find what holidays were and
and um said that collective bargaining
for state employees could or for any
government employees could uh rearrange
different days and uh allowed up to
three hours unpaid for private sector
employees to go vote and that's the bill
that's the structure and I'm happy to
take
questions thank you representative
Howard thank you for taking my question
uh so just for clarity uh section one
here where there's the actual embolden
language that does not actually affect
whether or not uh there's a day off
correct right section one is um
essentially adding the primaries uh
section one is adding the primaries to
that currently existing list of state
holidays which we do not have
any definition of what we do on a state
holiday it's just here's a list it's
it's it's um it's a t it's an honorary
title really to have a state holiday um
and then section uh the new section
section two is then going back and
defining what those state holidays
actually do okay thank
you all right representative
Bailey thank
you doesn't this tend to favor those who
belong to parties in the primary
elections like something like 40 45% of
the
population does not belong to a party
yeah yeah and because so for full
disclosure before I ver ran for office I
was an Undeclared and a co-founder of
New Hampshire independent voters um and
while in office I somewhat notoriously
went independent so um I the interests
of independent voters is something very
near and dear to me I don't believe in
our two-party system for personal um
disclosure I because famous ly um
boss what was his name Boss Tweed said
that I don't care who gets to vote as
long as I pick the
candidates because if you're forced to
choose
between um hamburger in Salsbury
stake you don't have much of a
selection and so really a lot of I I
briefly mentioned this but a lot of the
real democracy or Republic go it happens
in the primary level it's unfortunate
because as a state pay for private
entities to operate their own primaries
um when that's not actually you know
something it's it's we're paying for a
private institution however the reason
we do that is because it's so essential
to our
democracy primaries who is actually
going to be on the ballot is so
essential to our democracy that it's
worth us investing in um also famously
or infamously Texas back in the days of
Jim Crow when much of the South had poll
taxes and tests to prevent black people
from voting Texas didn't do that they
just said that um black people could
vote in the general election no problem
no test no pull taxes um but only white
people could vote in the
primary you see how that's a problem so
primaries are incredibly important I
also with you bemoan the fact that the
private parties are such a force in our
current system I have other bills and
other committees to deal with that is
issue but in terms of election day and
whether or not we should honor it as a
holiday to get people out and active if
you are a party member or UND declared
as long as we don't switch your ability
to to uh participate in the primary as
an Undeclared voter um That's essential
no matter who you are at currently you
get to participate in the primary even
if you're
Undeclared thank you other questions
representative Sellers and then the
lay thank you than Madam chair how many
employees would this
affect so I don't have off the top of my
head a number of state employees and in
technically it would affect all
employees that are scheduled to work on
Election Day because it also gives time
offer the private sector but in terms of
just a holiday it affects all government
employees in the
state except of course the moderators
Selectmen and supervisors of the
checklist that are required to to work
on the ction itself which is put into
that um new section as well as essential
services like police officers
firefighters um all normal
representative leam thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
bringing this to us um I say that you
say that it would be unpaid three hours
off but I don't see that specified
anywhere in that
language was oh um a previous version of
the bill did say uh unpaid but the
lawyer the drafting uh
attorney uh said that it wasn't because
we're not specifying that it has to be
paid it defaults to the employer doesn't
have to pay thank
you all right thank you and I would like
to mention for your edification that the
classic form of town meeting is a form
of direct democracy oh that's right
thank you for the correction I I was
speaking on the the national level
there's no national government in the
world but you are absolutely right and
Zing um good morning for the record my
name is Olivia zinc I'm the executive
director of open democracy and I live in
Franklin New Hampshire where where I
vote um I am testifying in support of
House Bill uh 52 this bear uh open
democracy is a nonpartisan nonprofit um
that believes that um everyone should be
participating um this does make that
designation um in the primary and the
presidential primary um establishing
legal holidays will make New Hampshire
more accessible for the average voters
especially working parents um busy young
professionals I had a neighbor who
wanted to vote in the primary and said
to me me
oh the primary was yesterday they had no
idea the date of the primary and I think
that whatever we can do to elevate
knowledge of the date of Elections um is
is important for us is in Civic life um
roughly about 60% of average citizens
show up to cast a ballot this is vastly
different in primaries and I actually
just pulled up the state primary from
2024 um
72,000 dependent voters Undeclared
voters voted in the um last September
primary um and uh Undeclared is the
largest um representative body we have
in the state um I do think it's
important for us to to move the needle
closer to additional participation in
our democracy so that every voter's
voice can be heard um making an election
day is highly
favorable on both sides of the aisle
according to a poll done in 24 um 72% of
Americans support making Election Day a
national holiday and this was 68% of
Republicans and 78% of democratic voters
um everyone benefits when we take
advantage of um making a more active
role of participating in elections um it
is clear that voters want um
politics to be in place for casting
their ballots to be less stressful this
past election many stood in line
especially in larger cities for a couple
of hours um if you are newly registered
I know that was the long line in my poll
um this last polling place this last
November um so I do think giving um
people three hours off um is a
good good Benchmark um I know the New
Hampshire businesses for social
responsibility did do a campaign for
their um members on time off on ction
day for for voters to work um and for
for these reasons I urge the committee
to vote a to pass on House Bill 52 and
I'm happy to take any
questions thank you representative Leon
um thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here to ask questions I
perhaps should have also asked this of
the sponsor but um I I didn't recognize
the question previously um in New
Hampshire we have good turnout at the
state elections but we have absolutely
dismal turnout at the local election
level where most of our property tax
are assessed um I'm curious if you think
that it would be equally important to
drive turnout to those local elections
as you would the state level given the
difference in turnouts I would I would
also love if the Secretary of State
published a date of all the local
elections and I would love if Municipal
Town governments put the date of their
local elections on their website because
we've been going through town websites
to try to find the dates of town meeting
and it's hard to find that information
and uh I was just talking to a voter in
Peterboro yesterday that was trying
trying to get information on their
school district elections and was
struggling to try to find out who the
candidates were 10 days after the filing
period had ended for that so I think
that we could as a society do a a very
much better job of
publicizing who's on the ballot the date
of the election the times the polling
places are El are um we we participated
open democracy did a survey that we
presented to the Secretary of State we
found out that it's easier to register
your
than to register to vote um by going to
town websites because that information
is much more readily available than the
information on registering to vote on
Town websites so we yes we can do a
better job thank you
represento thank you Miss in for being
here um I just had a question regarding
um the dates of our um elections do you
think that um the primary date also
drives down turnout same with um local
election dates I'm thinking back to our
Franklin ele ctions um this last year
having um the October local elections
wedged right between the September and
November elections and we only got very
low turnout so do you think successive
elections like that also stifle um
people's ability to go out and
vote um well I I think that publicizing
the date and making sure that there's
availability for people to to take time
off to participate is is critically
important um I I on personally on record
I've been on record that the city of
Franklin should move our October
election date to November because like
other municipalities we have have a city
election in November um instead of
having an annual September October
November election um it's a lot for our
poll workers too uh I think also within
this uh we used to not have a TR trouble
recruiting pole workers but right now
there are lots of shortages pole workers
across the state too so I do think
making an election day holiday would
allow people who might be state
employees who have the day off like I
know my moderator has to take a vacation
day to be the moderator as a state
employee um but this might give them
time off in order to not have to use a
vacation day um to to administer
elections which I think is is is a is
more work than their full-time job um to
be at the polls of the be the opening of
the of the polling place and and do
everything that you know I our our city
clerk one year worked a 24-hour day she
got to work at 4 in the morning and by
the time everything was counted it was
4M so I think we we should recognize the
value of of the work that does have to
happen on Election Day and if there are
more people that could participate as
election workers and do that Civ civil
Duty that would be
important for our state thank you other
questions
represent
Schmidt thank you madam
chair so the there are some downsides
obviously to to making it a
um legal holiday and in in the past when
we've had similar bills or even
identical bills that's been one of the
objections that have led to the bill
being itail um so
uh I'm not seeing anyone other than the
two of you here today um but uh have you
gone through and looked at the downsides
in terms of the lost wages or or lost um
uh is is is going to be a paid
holiday my my understanding is it's not
a paid holiday but but I I don't know
that I uh representative Reed could
speak more to that but I think um we we
should also look at what's the downside
when people don't participate in
elections um and and I think there is a
cost to people not participating and not
feeling like they are voice matters and
they even know the date of of Elections
um followup followup so uh um have you
looked at the at the reality that that
our election days um uh are not um
they are not ve very seasonally
appropriate in my opinion having an
election day on in the first week in
November can be a terrible day to have
to stand out in the cold for hours um we
had I think quite a nice day for
election day uh this past time it was
warm and we're all standing out there
going like how can this be election day
we're not freezing to death um but have
you looked at possibly moving the the
days around to to be we're we're not
needing the day off for Harvest anymore
so that's one of the reasons why it is
where it is have you looked at that I I
believe election day is set in our
constitution so we would need a
constitutional amendment to change the
first
Tuesday uh but but I think that there
has been efforts of people I know that
there's been conversations about moving
it to other countries do elections on
Sundays or other days um I so I think
that there's been research done on
what's the what's the best day to have
elections but I think to move our
elections there has been conversation in
the election law committee about moving
the DAT of the state primary to a
different date and as we we know the pre
uh the presidential primary date is set
by the Secretary of State often not very
much notice of the the date of the
presidential primary is given out too um
and I and that is a February uh We've
also had Town meetings on snow days a
lot of a lot of communities have had a
foot of snow on election days so I I I
agree with you that maybe it's not the
best weather day but I I think that
there we should look at all of the
solutions but I think this is a good
first step on um providing more
opportunity for additional civic
participation thank you for your effort
and researching this
other
helpful thank you madam chair and thank
you honorable members for uh recognizing
me again um first I did a brief um
internet search
approximately of our population of 1.3
million people 10,000 people apparently
roughly brief internet search are either
state or town employees this wouldn't
affect all of them as the chair um
rightly pointed out um however in the
question of paid versus
unpaid it's not technically a paid
holiday however there's caveats to that
first of all most state employees are uh
union members or fall under a Union
contract more specifically and those
contracts may include paid for holiday
days secondly if you're a salaried
employee um that may it's not a direct
cost you're not paying extra for things
you're not getting but you're losing a
day of work my argument for that is that
I think on a day where you have people
coming in late to work because they had
to go to the polls people leaving early
from work because they have to go to the
polls or people taking long lunch breaks
because they had to go to the polls
you're not losing that much productivity
from that extra day just being given off
um um also hourly employees would
actually represent a savings to the
state because you're not paying those
hourly employees who are now getting the
day off um as well as some overhead for
for that now I think at the end of the
day you're looking at mostly a uh a kind
of wash but it's essentially the cost of
a snow day minus the plows right it's
the it's the productivity loss that we
experience on a snow day and the
question is is a democracy worth that
democracies are expensive democracies
are messy and they are worth all of it
they're worth every penny um the last
piece I wanted to say on the town level
is that um so most schools schools that
operate as a polling place are closed
now on Election Day there was a time
when uh schools would some schools would
try to remain open then the question of
our guns and polling places allowable
came and so schools just decided to to
close so we're already closing those
schools so that's already basically a
snow day anyway on a Tuesday so I think
the point is it's worth it culturally
it's worth it logistically to give
people the day off to go vote the time
to go vote the time to take their
children who are already off of school
and they probably need to stay home from
work to take care of the kids anyway the
time to take them into the polling place
and show them democracy at work but the
more valuable thing we get out of that
is that people know they're going to
have this day off they see it coming up
on calendar they're thinking about the
idea of Civic engagement they're
thinking about their civic duty and it
be it shifts us culturally to caring
more about engaging with our government
because our government is
US
Schmid thank you madam chairman have you
given uh any thought to special election
situations obviously they're limited to
that District um but it's also very
important and it's also an expense to
the local community when they have to um
run the election because they have to
have the pole workers and so forth so
it's a big deal in a way for the town to
have to come up with an extra three or
$4,000 which is easily is have you given
any thought to that I have given thought
to special elections I have given
thought to local elections Municipal
elections I didn't include them in this
bill because I thought this was a big
enough ask as it was if this committee
saw fit to include all of those things
in this bill I would be as happy as a
clam but having said that I think it's
best to get the big stuff while we can
and it's better to have something over
nothing thank you okay other other
questions all right not seeing any thank
you for represent oh representative
settlers thank you thank you madam chair
so my concern is and you mentioned it is
equality among employees some a salary
some a union and some of them are hourly
those hourly ones wouldn't be paid but
the other two could be
paid so right hourly employees would
stand who who by the way almost all of
our state employees are under a Union
contract so even the hourly employees
are still under a Union contract there's
nothing preventing them from getting um
that in a contract and saying we had the
day off we need to be paid for that day
and in fact that's explicitly um talked
about in the bill um It also says that
if you have the day off you can or you
can you might have to work that day but
then you get another day off in exchange
so the only people who would be
experiencing an actual monetary loss
would potentially be those hourly
workers experiencing a loss of one day
of work but most of those are in a Union
contract where they could easily
negotiate I don't know about easily but
could negotiate and may already have a
negotiation in place that pays them for
state holidays thank you other
questions all right very good thank you
again Madam is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill 52
obviously not all right then I'm going
hearing sure all right in that case
we're going into executive session does
someone have a motion representative
Howard I want to move a to pass on uh uh
hb52 I'll second that
motion that was thetion you B who
seconded it okay thank
you Howard and TBO uh represent Howard
do you wish to speak to your motion yes
I will thank you uh Madam chair this
bill helps provide our citizens access
to their rights and perform their civic
duty it it does not force private
employers to give employees the day off
or pay them for their time missed we are
also struggling to recruit pole workers
currently and this would help us provide
potential volunteers uh and with that I
uh hope that you will all support the
Bill thank
you repres T I would agree with what
representative Howard said I think it's
really good to increase turnout and I
would also point out the logistical
hurdles that come with st schools being
open on Election Day it prevents
students who are old enough to vote from
being able to vote and it um creates
those logistical hurdles that
representative Reed mentioned with
Firearms being carried in schools that
are typically gun-free zones so in light
of that and the fact that um encouraging
voter turnout is always a positive thing
I would also encourage an a to pass
you okay I would like to since nobody
else seems to want to talk I'd like to
say that I'm I'm opposed to this because
it seems to
give government
workers additional holidays that private
sector workers don't have even if they
can take a couple of hours off it for it
forces a
uh it forces the taxpayers to fund extra
pay because I'm I'm sure that even
though this bill doesn't say so they
government workers will expect to be
paid for their time off or uh in the
case of election workers they're their
hard their hardworking
time
um
and I think it it's a
however we want to get people to
vote it is possible to learn when the
are and if you don't care enough to find
out I'm not sure that we need to to
force you to vote so I'm
opposed representative Sellers and then
scitec thank you madam chair uh on those
on that line there is I would rather see
a state holiday than just a government
holiday because it's again you are
putting the government employees in a
class of employees saying hey we're
going to give you the right to take up
to three hours off but any other
business in the state you f yourself and
it just doesn't seem like we're treating
everybody with equality and like the
repres
sitech this just seems uh to be getting
very complicated and I'm not uh I don't
see anything particularly wrong with the
the situation as it is now with the
three hours given to people who can who
want to be off as um so it I don't think
C The Cure is that the problem needs
this this complex a cure the other thing
is I'm going to say something that's you
may not want to hear I'm if people don't
want to vote I don't want them to vote I
want informed voters who care about
democracy not about people being
compelled urged uh to get out lightly
informed voters I'm I'm just not just
not in favor of that okay r l
uh thank you madam chair um I do think
that this has an issue where it ends up
having two classes of people you have
state employees and local employees who
have the full day off in order to do
this and then you have what probably
will end up being restricted to only
three days off for people at private
employers because once you set a certain
limit a lot of people will treat that as
a floor um Additionally you have the
challenge where in my town we have a
number of different schools um we've
been having elections at Pinkerton but
we've kept other schools open especially
because that creates other child care
issues when you're moving people around
having a one-sized fits-all approach to
this is a bit of a challenge and most
importantly how is an employee going to
show that they're three hours away from
work or for voting are they going to
bring something that says that they
voted in the Republican primary and then
they're telling their employer that
they're voting Republican or likewise
that they voted in the Democrat primary
now at that point when does this become
a discussion about who you're voting
about voting for um to your employer and
I think that this is while while really
well-intentioned I think that this
brings a slippery slope representative
de and then
Pearson I'll gu to representative
Pearson oh representative
Pearson sen what you do in a primary
election is public information so that
that one's not
gonna how someone votes and which card
they pull is you can get so that's um
I'm I'm trying to I'm trying to wrestle
with this because the concept I I don't
have a problem with um you know
we we love to talk
about turnout and all of the efforts
that go with that and that effort which
has been going on for a long time has
Merit um the other the other thing to
wrestle here as far as the giving giving
this to one group or or
another we have a bit of an ideological
conflict in the sense that are we as the
government going to start to force
private
Enterprise to give time off to people
that is generally
not something that the Republican party
is been doing we've been we've been
hands off so we we kind of we're kind of
in a bit of a conundrum here in the
sense
that do we you know the idea of of a
state holiday which has Merit in in
making this you know a day off for
everybody then does the argument of
mandating this on a on private
so I'm more I'm more leaning towards the
I the idea that we don't really
interfere with private businesses on
this one but
um I can't see shutting this concept off
we we the argument that representative
Reed made is in reference to some of the
other holidays we have and and not that
we're valuing one over another or
stacking them or raing them or any of
that but the the concept that that the
great experiment as it was once called
um does
not facilitate ways in which its people
can exercise that experiment to me is a
little weird so
um so I I think that you know we we've
got to we've got to wrestle with with
where the ideological split occurs here
and what our intended goals are here and
for that right now I'm lean in I will
lean in favor of
autopass Representative D thank you
madam chair um I have a couple of points
I'd like to make is we pride ourselves
here in uh the granite state on being
the first in the nation and yet don't
give state employees the day off um so I
think that that weighs in favor of that
argument if we were to pass this where
vote ought to pass um I also am a small
business owner and the the article here
sorry the language here on line 20 it
says all other employers shall when
practicable allow employees up to three
hours away from work um I think that
that is language of
encouragement um and I think that's
something that we should be supporting
um I as a small business owner was so
compelled by the testimony that happened
here today um we're going to we're going
to make it a a day off for for our team
um and in Hampton in this most recent
presidential election Hampton where I'm
from some people were standing in line
up to two to two and a half hours um
waiting to vote and I think that
allowing three or encouraging 3 hours
for private employers um makes a lot of
sense because sometimes the lines are
pretty particularly long so I I'm going
to be voting in favor of a I'm going to
vote for autopass thank you
representative
BR thank you um I do want to say that
we've heard this bill
before and we have also heard um reasons
not to support it and I'm encouraged to
hear all the reasons to vote for it and
I can understand the difficulty in
making that
decision um this doesn't mandate anyone
to vote this doesn't mandate anyone to
do anything other than think about the
day as a voting day and if that's moves
the
needle then that's fine because that's
what we're supposed to be doing
democracy is
work so I'll be supporting the bill
although in the past I had not I will
this
time represent Leon thank you madam
chair um I do recognize that our voting
records are available and we can find
out which way that somebody has voted
however having an excused absence for
voting just really increases the need
for somebody to look into somebody's
voting history and I I see that as a
trouble um I do agree that we shouldn't
be mandating things on small businesses
or any private businesses and since this
would be a disparity between public
employees and private employees I think
that that's a good reason not to do this
in the first place and that is why I
will be opposing this okay represent
power
I just wanted to say that online we had
83 people in support in three in
opposition thank you thank you
representive
sellers thank you m my last Point first
of all I like the idea of getting the
day off I do I think that's great
especially for elections you know get
people to
participate however there is no fiscal
note and if we are giving employees 3
hours off times 10,000 employees times
$25 an hour or there BS you know we're
starting to add up into a just for that
one day towards towards a million
dollars yes thank you representative Lon
you have a comment on that um yes thank
you madam chair um I I just wanted to
point out to representative sellers that
that three hours is for the non
non-government employees this likely
would be interpreted as a full day off
for both the primary the presidential
primary and election day and any of
these other days that they may or may
not be taking off as a holiday so this
has potential of being a very
significant fiscal note um and further I
would state that if we have the day off
perhaps we don't need to have the
exemption to the absentee ballots that
if you need to work you can take an
absentee ballot because if we're
guaranteeing the day off perhaps that
exemption wouldn't be needed
then
yes I was going to point out that if you
are are working all day and can't get to
the
polls you can get an absentee ballot now
it's one of the legitimate reasons for
an absentee ballot and I know people
that do so I will also mention that I uh
once worked for a company that had whose
Union had negotiated election day as a
holiday which
was in most cases the most useless
holiday you could ever have because it's
on a Tuesday in early
November and unless you were a hunter
which it there's not much really going
on on Tuesday in November um but we had
it off so presumably so that they could
ensure everybody went to the local
polls
um anyway any other comments questions
issues or dargie no okay all right the
motion is ought to pass by represent
role Vice chairman Leon
no votes no representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey nay
representative uh Shan no Representative
sers no Representative no
representative tibo yes representative
groa yes representative Schmidt yes
representative Davis yes representative
dargy yes representative Howard yes
representative stes yes
97 97 ought to pass all right the motion
uh passes
9-7 represent power at your very
earliest convenience does someone wish
to write a Minority Report this will not
be on the regular
calendar this will be will it will be on
said fine it will be on the regular
calendar excuse does someone wish to
write a Minority Report I'm willing to
write it if nobody else does well okay
representative land will write a
Minority
Report and we are off until 1:15 which
time I just want to REM remind those on
the subcommittee uh for building codes
minutes
e
hello and W welcome back to the
executive Department's Administration
committee um we are going to open the
hearing on House Bill 89 by watching the
now
e
thank you and with that I'll call the
prime sponsor representative Joe
Alexander
um thank you Madame chair members of
executive departments Administration
hopefully this is your afternoon
entertainment for the day I really try
to split things up in a day of
monotonous public hearings but um my
name is representative Joe Alexander I
represent the town of gtown um I'm here
to introduce hb89 um a bill that is is
done by a Creator who grew up in gtown
but is very New Hampshire based um film
and as you can see this this is a story
about the a story about the creation of
the Old Man of the Mountain um I had
first met Griffin a couple years ago uh
when he had asked um called me as his
State Rep because he was very upset out
of it uh because a historical marker was
being taken from um someplace around the
state house and he was communicating
that with me and we we had got to
talking and um we stayed connected
through that and when I heard that he
was producing a film about the creation
of the Old Man of the Mountain a story
about it um I had offered to put this in
um this is a story first of all a love
story um between Sawyer and carrian but
it's it's one story of many that can be
attributed to the creation of the Old
Man of the Mountain The Old Man of the
Mountain is a symbol of the state and
many do not know who the landmark is and
you know as somebody who grew up in New
Hampshire I was I think seven or eight
years old when the Old Man of the
Mountain fell but I think a lot of
students and and children in New
Hampshire don't know who this symbol is
and they might be like hey Mom like
why is this old man on a on a root sign
driving down the highway they don't know
who this person is I think this is a
very creative way to depict the story
around the creation a story around the
creation of the old man um that can be
marketed towards young people so that
they can feel like they are part of the
culture and creation of our most
important symbol that of of the state um
I I also think briefly it draws on some
key things that uh we as Granite Staters
consider Granite State values I mean
love perseverance the lack of greed um
hard work the fact that Sawyer was
Untouched by greed I think is important
I think it's a key value to granted
State citizen so um with that the
Creator is here um to present the film
but I just wanted to introduce it and uh
thank you should vote off to pass thank
you thank you are there any questions
from the committee for the sponsor see
none thank you very much and next I'll
didn't so as you sit down if you can
push the button on the thing so the red
comes on the microphone yes thank you uh
thank you thank you madam chair and
honorable members of the committee I
find myself in the unique position to be
seated before you today to talk about
the merits and the qualities of a film
that I directed and I co-wrote there's
only only so much that I can say before
it sounds boastful thus I sit here today
on behalf of the over 30 talented young
artists who brought within the crystal
Hills to life artists from a vast array
of backgrounds diverse backgrounds races
and beliefs from the granite state and
Beyond artists whose Artistry and
dedication to Unique Vision made this
film the success and the achievement
that we believe it to be like many of
them I grew up loving to draw and tell
stories as a student at Maple Avenue
Elementary School in gtown I used to
draw comics in the panels of my math
worksheets much to my teachers Chagrin
naturally but I've always been very
lucky to know precisely what I wanted to
do make animated stories and yet there
were obstacles I remember being in high
school and meeting with a guidance
counselor who I told I wanted to go to
arts school and her response was why
you're so smart to some extent that
exact question is the reason I am here
before you to me the Arts have always
been an Avenue to explore extraordinary
creative opportunities meet some of the
most important people in my life and
express my way if rather express myself
in ways words fail to do for this
committee to approve House Bill 89 would
not be for them to hand me an Accolade
for my resume but a chance for them to
show artists in New Hampshire young and
old that the pursuit of artistic
self-expression is nothing to be
discouraged from it can build
communities promote local history and
culture and lead to a more fulfilled
being I'd like to explore one of those
points if I may in writing this film my
co-writer Christina corales and I dove
into local Legends and mythology from
the abanaki to Nathaniel Hawthorne and
immersed ourselves in the research of
the Franconia Heritage Museum the New
Hampshire historical society and our
national parks service approval of House
Bill 89 sends a clear message that
stories woven from New Hampshire's deep
tapestry of tradition history and
culture are valuable you can find great
inspiration for your creativity from the
efforts of your local historical
societies and libraries and while our
film is a completely original
reimagining of the Old Man of the
Mountain the way it pulls from such a
wide range of influences to craft a new
narrative inspires viewers to come up
with their own story Ries about the
iconic profile this in turn leads to the
aformentioned journey into local history
and creative expression every member of
this committee sits here today because
at some point in their lives somebody
told them that they can follow their
dreams of leadership think about it for
just a moment who told you you can this
film tells artists in New Hampshire they
can they can make meaningful connections
through ART they can find inspiration
through learning about their beautiful
state they can be a little boy from gown
who can grow up to sit before this
committee and ask them to consider a
film they made with their friends to
represent all that is Limitless and
inspiring not just about New Hampshire
but the Arts thank you thank you are
there questions from the
committee um I have a question you said
that this is a reimagining based upon
different Tales um my question is just
um if you think that having this be the
granite state animated film would make
people think that this is the one true
history as opposed to one reimagining
that's a fantastic point I think that
that is definitely one way to to look at
the situation but by no regards or of
course by the the film that we watch
today does it present itself as the
story does it present itself as the only
story and Christina the co-writer and I
are quite open about the fact that we
came up with it all ourselves it's a
wholly original narrative the idea it as
I mentioned of course being that people
who would watch this film and know not
only our story but the story is told by
generations of storytellers before us
will hopefully Inspire them to want to
become storytellers as well and be that
through film or animation or music or
poems or anything of the sort they'll
find a way to express themselves
creatively thank you representative sers
yeah thank you madam chair um very good
I can't even do stick figures thank you
but in any case case um how would you
feel if someone came forward a year or
two or three or five for now and wanted
to have their story out there instead of
yours I mean so you're the only person
we've seen on the story correct as far
as the uh animated I suppose at present
yes yeah so I'm just trying to figure
what happens what happens as a committee
or as a legislator you know five people
come forward next year and they would
like like they're animated up there I
think that given the fact that the state
of New Hampshire has existed for as long
as it has and the medium of Animation
has existed for as long as it has and
hasn't yet inspired a bill of this sort
or a film of this sort might speak to
some degree to the fact that people
maybe haven't felt motivated to be able
to bring this story or to reimagine this
story into animation and while they are
of course welcome to do so and of course
welcome to come to the committee and ask
them to reconsider their position on
within the crystal Hills the idea of
somebody watching the film and then of
course coming forward to the committee
again and asking for a reintroduction of
a new idea would in my mind not be
something that I'd discourage in fact it
would be something I'd be incredibly
encouraged by because again it's shown
that this story and the fact that the
state has chosen to recognize the merits
of this story and the artists who've
worked on it is a way to represent that
this story is something that will make
other people want to come up with their
own ideas want to tell their own stories
or as I mentioned uh to the chairwoman
there anything of the
sort thank you uh representative
citec did you give any thought to
incorporating the old woman of the
mountain well I'm aware I'm aware of her
and of course of of a dozen things up
there in the whites of course there's
the um whatever the mountain is that the
resort is named after Lincoln or or
whatever it is and there's the chicken
farmer Rock in Newber or or or so on and
so forth there's a dozen things of the
sort in our state and again as I as I
speak to the merits of how hopefully
artists will watch this and be inspired
to create their own narratives I I spoke
to the representative there about
perhaps new stories about the Old Man of
the Mountain but that is of course not
to Discount the fact that anything in
our state can I believe be cause for a
great sense of inspiration I'm sure that
every single representative here can
think about something in their own
Hometown that they've heard a dozen
stories about told a dozen different
ways and as I've alluded to to be able
to legitimize the idea of Animation
being a medium in which these stories
can be told so fully and with so much
life is in a way to hopefully encourage
people to look into their own town
histories their own libraries and come
cool there are other questions from the
committee saying none thank you very
much and thank you for bringing your
work in today thank you for having me um
I have cards from both Paul poo and
Denise poo I didn't know if you wanted
to speak together or
separately okay um then I'll call I'll
call you both whatever you prefer I just
didn't want to separate you if you did
not want to
be representing two different entities
thread neach um indel was Denise pulio
Saga was Paul pulo sag Ka Sak pent abaki
people T New Hampshire Commission on
Native American Affairs
thank you um hi hello friends my name is
Denise pulio I'm the head female speaker
of the kaac band of the pentaco abnaki
people and this is Paul pulio um uh he
is representing the New Hampshire
Commission on Native American
Affairs I was chosen to come before you
today and I greetings to all of you uh
committee members um I'm now the
commission uh chair of the Native
American Commission on Native American
Affairs
uh our commission is uh under the
department of uh natural and cultural
resources it is also represented by the
New Hampshire arts and tourism so when I
come here with a heavy heart saying that
we're in opposition to
89 it's on the Merit of this being um in
any way constructive for the fact that
we're going into our 250th year and
we're looking at our history of our
state and the White Mountains are part
of that um we had a meeting on uh
January 13th and this bill was brought
up and unanimously the commission uh
felt it uh it really didn't uplift the
uh the history of the state in the way
that we expected that would be part of
the Benchmark part of the the threshold
that you'd have for an animated film for
New Hampshire you're legislatively
putting something in place which really
doesn't have a lot of historical con uh
content in it
um people you know always talk about the
White Mountains the crystal mountains
this goes way back to the 1500s when
early explorers were on the ocean and
looking at the White Mountains and they
were what were they were seeing was the
micer and the granite reflecting the
sunlight and that's how the name um you
know Crystal mountains it had nothing to
do with diamonds or crystals in the
mountain it had to do with the
reflection of the sunlight on the uh on
the
granite the commission felt that um
there are so many indigenous stories
some of which have actually been put
into short films that talk about The
Love Story and how uh Bill old man the
mountain or his Old Stone Face is one of
the other terms we've used uh became
part of the mountain and how uh the
mountain fell down in a love
reconnection of the past uh so the story
line is somewhat similar to in the
Indigenous stories but uh the indigenous
stories uh don't talk about uh iron
mining uh they don't talk about diamonds
in the mountains um which we felt was
where this went too far this is a cute
film but it doesn't really belong as
something that's legislatively elevated
to the level of State prominence it's an
interesting artwork and I agree that uh
was artsy and everybody uh loves the
narration but these stories go way back
and what this does it says a precedent
that you're erasing the of a rich
stories that have been you know
documented all through the 1800s and all
the way up into the into the 1900s there
were stories about the White Mountains
and then lo and behold when the mountain
fell down uh a whole series of
narratives came back from the Native
American communities talking about how
that's a re reuniting loved ones so this
is this has been going on for a while in
fact the alpinist magazine actually had
a docu had a an article on the same
narrative that was done in 2002 so this
is nothing um like it's not a lack of
some resources out there it's just the
commission didn't feel this should have
been elevated to the point of being a
state film and the other ones that are
out there and other narratives could be
easily made into a a state movie if you
wanted it to have some historical cons
uh consistency with the uh the white
mountains and why it's called the
crystal mountains with that being said
um we just don't want to see the
indigenous narratives being totally
erased and this is what will happen with
this this will be elevated and be used
and say well there is no no worthy
stories from the indigenous perspective
from the past and we we just think it's
going in the wrong direction and
shouldn't be done and it's a nice ey
project I don't want to discredit that
but it's just not appropriate at this
level of legislation I just think it's
so it's so low fruit it shouldn't even
be put on as a a state short animated
perspective I'm not going to waste your
time and repeat everything that he said
so um uh but with that being said um as
a tribe we do agree that the indigenous
um perspective of the foundation of the
old man in the mountain and of the White
Mountains is an important um uh
story to convey into the future um and
with that I will say no more thank you
other questions from the committee
representative sers yeah thank you madam
chair so you're not opposed to having a
state short film you just wanted to be
more inclusive of the entire history
from basically from when we settled or
before we settled to today that that's
correct um it's all about uh
you know we're going for the time period
250s is coming up we're looking at all
of our history we're looking at all the
all stories and there was so much Rich
stuff written about the White Mountains
in the 1800s and this is not one of
those stories and we wish that it's just
bad timing there could have been
somebody out there that developed a very
cute story which we already have um out
there it's actually on YouTube there is
a short animated story just like this
that talks about it from the indigenous
perspective and it all ties in because
it does make sense how the Stone Face
came on the mountain this one kind of
alludes to he he was trapped and died in
there but the the other narrative was uh
a warrior stayed on the top of Canon
Mountain waiting for his loved one to
return all for a winter and the old man
winter just destroyed him and made him
part of the mountain so it's a more
acceptable narrative because it had some
kind of connection way back in the past
and when it fell this narrative was that
he was re reunited with his loved one
who died just about the same time that
he did so it it it made more sense that
if there was ever going to be one it had
to do with how the Stone Face got
created in the first place not the other
way around so if that makes sense thank
you representative
Bailey would it help if it was this is a
bill to make it the state film would
help if it was a state film allowing for
other to come along I think if you were
going to make it a one of U many state
films then um then that a bill should be
passed with all those State
films together um right now if you pass
this bill as it's written um it's going
to erase the indigenous narrative and we
can come back a year from now um because
incc which is indigenous New Hampshire
collaborative Collective um we have
funding we can we can create an animated
film for you within six months and and
have it in front of this in order for
the 250th um but we want something
that's historically accurate that
pertains to the state and that has um
long long longevity um to the foundation
of um New Hampshire um and this story as
um as you already heard was recently
created and it doesn't have the history
um that we would be hoping for within a
state
film thank you I I think it also gives a
disserving with diamonds in the in Canon
mountain or anywhere in the White
Mountains I don't know if that's going
to bur on anybody to think that way but
it's just it's a bad construct it had to
do with micro it had nothing to do with
diamonds no
crystals there other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much for bring bringing your perspective
I appreciate it thank you thank you very
much
uh and I'll call Brian
Hansen okay thank you is there anybody
else here to speak on the
bill um with that I will close the
889 and
um um we can open we'll open an
executive session in five minutes just
to see if there's anybody who's missing
from here yeah yes so we'll be back in
session
e
looks like we're all here yes except
represent Davis he had the bill
somewhere
else what's
that yes
yes
um
does do you have a motion or does
someone have a motion uh yes Madam chair
um I would make an motion of an
expedient to legislate on House Bill 89
second okay I did see them
move thank you representative Schmidt
for sharing your
experience so the motion is inexpedient
to legislate by representative Lon
second by representative Schmidt do you
to speak to your motion uh yes thank you
madam chair I think this is a wonderful
beautifully done story um done in
animation it's beautiful that there is
no AI used in it because um it's
beautiful to still see hand done
animation um I'm just very concerned
that if we have this as the state
animation film a lot of people are going
to see this as the history when it's one
interpretation and we have long-standing
Traditions um through the ab abanaki and
I would not want to erase that history
by by promoting this to be our state
animated film um I do want to commend Mr
Hansen on his amazing work um and I do
want to say that us recommending this to
not become the state animated film is no
knock against the wonderful work he has
done the soundtrack that they had in the
amazing narration but just simply that
we want to make sure that we're not
erasing um long-standing history by
promoting this film this
Viewpoint thank you representative
Schmidt thank you madam chair so uh I'm
troubled by several aspects of the film
number one is that it's a complete
fiction and has nothing to do with the
reality of uh of uh the old man of the
mount and so forth um I I watched the
film very carefully about three weeks
ago uh and uh it's it's just not
appropriated appropriate uh especially
given the fact that it has no
competition I mean we we'd be selecting
one out of one and and I don't think
that's fair to to other artists who may
be thinking in terms of something having
nothing to do with the Old Man of the
Mountain so uh itl is the correct Motion
in my view thank you thank you does
anyone else have a comment uh yes
represent long and then sitech uh I like
to repres presid Bailey's proposal to
make it one to make it a state animated
film instead of the state animated film
so uh if anyone would like
to uh guess I could offer an
amendment uh so I'd like to offer an
amendment to make it excuse me the
motion is inexpedient to legislate and
we can't offer an amendment at this
point but you certainly can talk about
what you think would have been better so
if it had been a State animated film uh
I would vote um against lling it but I
will be voting for itl uh because I
don't want to see other voices
excluded thank you representative
scitech I I have a different perspective
I have
generally a lot of trouble with State
anything where
is because I feel these kinds of things
semi ceremonial things tend to
trivialize the legislature we're voting
on taxation land use abortion rights of
people and then we bring in this and I
need to keep an open mind on it but my
my bias is that I'm not in favor in
general and I'm saying this because it
will apply in other um other legislation
likely to come before the committee
that's all thank you okay anyone else
concerns okay in that case the motion is
index me to legislate by representative
Lon and the clerk can call the
role Vice chair Lon please
yes clerk VES yes representative Pearson
yes representative Bailey yes
representative shim yes representative
sers yes representative yes
representative steo yes representative
groden yes representative Schmidt yes
representative um dargy
yes representative dver yes
representative long yes and the chair
yes 15 to
nothing okay motion pass passes 15 to Z
consent okay seeing none we'll put this
on
consent and we still have a couple of
minutes Madam chair can we um have a
discussion about a possible Amendment on
210 I want to float an idea before I go
through the process of paperwork and all
that jazz 210 reminding me is Commission
on the flag the commission on the flag
so um think thinking back
[Music]
to and in no way am I comparing
these the flag of the State of New
Hampshire to the symbol of the New
England Patriots but when you know in
the late 80s the New England Patriots
when they went to Rebrand themselves
went through a process of of opening
that up to submission and and they had a
procedure and a process of narrowing
that down and for those of us that are
old enough to remember that they they
did it right so looking at the the
legislation that we have here um one of
the things that jumped out at me was you
know there seemed to be reluctancy on um
lines 24 through 27 as far as the the
proposals and the commission's
potentially submitting a design and all
that so my thought process here is to uh
have the commission develop criteria and
a mechanism to accept designs submitted
by New Hampshire citizen
the commission will determine the length
of time for submission commission will
narrow down the submissions to 50 let's
I mean God only knows how money they're
going to receive uh commission will
determine as to how the final 50
submissions will be narrowed down and
the commission will hold a public
hearing once the 50 final submissions
have been
chosen the 50 is just a number I picked
but but basically the concept here is
that I mean if we're going to have a a
reboot of the of our state flag
let's bring this let's open this up to
the citizens of the state to submit to
this commission ideas and in
designs and and just go through that
process um rather than rather than
having a commission that's doing a lot
of work that may or may not be fruitful
and it seems to not
be popular with the committee
okay
represento I agree with representative
Pearson I think to solicit designs from
um the public is a much more logical
approach and it's what's been um um
attempted in other states like Utah and
in Minnesota that have changed their
Flags um quite successfully so I would
support um changing it so it can only
solicit rather than design the flag
representative Howard thank you as a
co-sponsor on HB 210 I am in complete
agreement with Representatives Pearson
and tibo I think that this is a
completely uh acceptable Amendment and
would uh help provide an opportunity for
public input uh that may not necessarily
be guaranteed thank you represent
scitech uh I'm not sure yet uh sounds um
reasonable enough I I'm thinking along
the line that Betsy Ross didn't need a
commission um but the other thing is if
to entertain this don't put a limit on
it if they're bad designs they can just
winow them out in a hurry but it just
looks funny to put a limit that's all
the the the concept of going down to 50
was just a for
if the only the only thing the only
thing is with that with representes
hitech is that we always run the risk
and and thinking back to some of the
other events that we've done here is if
the elementary schools jump on this we
will have thousands of submissions so
you're losing my vote you know okay uh
but I I gotta lay it out in the reality
of what what could potentially come of
this all
right I I'd like to comment that when we
considered the flag change last year
there were some people who just didn't
like the particular design we were
voting on but there was a very large
group within the house and within the
committee that was not convinced that
there was any need to change the flag at
all there may be Vex olical reasons it's
not perfect or even ideal but on the
other hand it's it's been our flag for
better than 300 years so sorry no 200
better than 200
years
so so your your submission will be the
current state
flag I'm not going to bother I don't
think it's worth our our time to change
something that has served us perfectly
well regardless of some some
individual's carping about how it's not
as good as it ought to be well there's a
whole lot of other things we have that
are not as good as they ought to be but
they work and I'm not in I'm personally
not willing to invest my time and energy
and fixing them and I think there is a
fair number of Representatives who feel
the same so um I'm just warning you that
if you bring an amendment it's going to
me with rousing indifference by a lot of
people
and that's why we're having this
discussion right now okay well it's your
choice represent yes chair mire maybe we
might take a straw vote could we take a
straw
vote uh we we have half a minute so yes
what's what do you want to vote
on whether or not we want to pass the
Bill okay as is or amended either way
yeah either way either way either way
those in favor raise your hand in favor
of what passing a bill in some form in
some form sure two
three four five six those
opposed two three four five six and then
there's a couple of other that makes
everything and there's a couple of other
people who don't care enough to even
vote so I would say it's at your own
risk sure
and I will get us out of executive
session open the hearing on House Bill
176 and invite up representative
wheeler oh representative done are you
presenting give us a pink card when
thank you madam chair good afternoon
Madam chair committee members and guests
I'm representative Ron dun from
Londoner I'm here today to sponsor this
bill that would change the New Hampshire
state flag this bill came to me because
of a young man sitting next to me Andrew
I first met Andrew when he came to the
lary town council meeting back in
January of
2024 since that time this bill has
developed into what you see here today
Andrew has been involved in the entire
process
he spoke with all the co-sponsors asked
them all to sign on he also had two
rejections of co-sponsors that he dealt
with um however that did not stop him he
found two
more uh some of you will like his flag
design of the left profile and some do
not so Andrew today has a handout that
shows both sides of the flag one with
the left profile one with the right
profile Andrews brought photos with him
and he's going to explain the difference
in his preference and why he chose a
certain
profile uh my committee today is an
executive session at 2:00 so I've got to
run across the hall I have total faith
in Andrew here that he will answer any
of your questions that you have and I
thank you for your time today Andrew I
turn over to you thank you
representative dun and good luck in your
executive session can you do that um Mr
flon thank you and I first wanted to ask
um I wanted to ask permission for a
prop we're much less formal here than in
the chamber you have a flag I believe
yes I noticed your one of your
yep good morning Madam chair and members
of the committee I am Andrew flockton of
Milford I am
13 I am testifying in support of House
Bill
176 submitted for me by representative
Dunn proposing my design for the state
flag of New Hampshire I served as New
Hampshire's 2024 governor for a day and
I'm a member of the North American
vexillological Association which studies
Flags the people of New Hampshire helped
me decide what to put on this flag this
speech will tell you why I think the
current state flag should be changed and
why these symbols are on my flag firstly
the current state flag of New Hampshire
basically consists of the state seal on
a blue background commonly called a seal
on a bed sheet the New Hampshire flag is
one of 27 that use their state seal or
code of arms and their flag and one of
24 flags with a blue
background
second the state flag is just liked by
both vexillologists and New Hampshire
citizens as well as being historically
inaccurate
in the 2001 State and provincial flag
survey by the North American Vex olical
Association New Hampshire ranked
41st or in other words the 10th worst
flag in the survey a quiz taken over
400,000 times ranked the New Hampshire
flag as America's second most
forgettable state flag California's flag
ranked as America's most memorable state
flag it is easily recognized iable like
California's flag is easily recognizable
this unique design will be a substantial
Improvement in 1909 when our state flag
was adopted there were at the same time
at least two bills both to put the old
man the mountain on the state flag
people have wanted the old man on the
state flag from the very beginning
thirdly The Old Man of the Mountain is a
distinct symbol to both new hampshirites
and people Nation wide The Old Man of
the Mountain is synonymous with New
Hampshire it is on the state emblem
license plates State root signs and the
New Hampshire state quor in 1850 the
famous Nathaniel Hawthorne who wrote
books like The Scarlet Letter wrote a
story called The Great Stone Face about
the Old Man of the Mountain armato live
for your die which was famously ritten
by General John Stark in 1809 is also a
synonymous symbol also Al featured on
the state emblem and license plates
there are also Nine Stars representing
New Hampshire being the ninth state
admitted to the union so for well over
175 years the people of New Hampshire
have held the Old Man of the Mountain
and Live Free or Die close to their
hearts I have spoken with flag experts
and shown them my design they seem to
like the Old Man of the Mountain and
Live Free or Die a simple design with
few colors and no States seal the
vexillologists would like a simple flag
although none of these vexillologists
are from New Hampshire they were seded
after I educated them on the symbolism
of the old man and Live Free or Die the
people of New Hampshire that I've talked
to like the flag that incorporates The
Old Man and Live Free or Die I've talked
to lots of people in New Hampshire and
the people that I've talked to and have
signed my petition want this flag design
I have talked to people that are not
from New Hampshire and even they
identify Live Free or Die an Old Man of
the
Mountain the people of New Hampshire are
very proud of both Live Free or Die and
the old man furthermore two states have
recently changed their Sia bed sheet
Flags Utah and Minnesota I think that
the design I'm proposing would be a
unique symbol of New Hampshire I think
it brings people together in these times
of dispute you may wonder how many
people visit the beautiful white
mountains at which the old man was
hustled well according to the forest
service the White Mountains receives
upwards of 6 million visitors annually
there is a field of white on my flag to
represent the White Mountains a large
majority of these visitors understand
the symbolism that the old man
represents for New Hampshire and as far
as Live Free or Die General Stark wrote
this as a toast to the Battle of
Bennington a battle which helped America
on its quest for dependence the F quote
is actually Live Free or Die death is
not the greatest of evils New Hampshire
is a state that fought to secure the
freedoms we all enjoy
today this flag would give the old man
representation on flag folds across the
state and putting Live Free or Die on
the flag serves as a commemoration to
our state's history and the freedoms we
all enjoy today joining them together on
my flag is what the people want I the
support of former Governor Kur Alderman
will Stewart and former Republican
nominee for congress Lily Tang Williams
HB 176 was also showcased by citizens
count on their podcast $100 plus mileage
and it is also being used as a lesson in
Civics by a New Hampshire homeschooling
Association some people like my design
as it is but I'm told some people have
support for my flag with silhouette as
it appears on license place plates I
just want to bring it to everyone's
attention that by darkening the
silhouette on the back side of the flag
the same as the front side of the flag
each side of the flag will show the old
man as it was in real life from one
perspective you see it this
way and from another perspective you see
it that way which is exactly what 6
million people a year would have seen as
they travel north and south on
i93 that is why I argue that if New
Hampshire's flag is changed it needs to
be a better and more effective flag to
represent New Hampshire everyone what do
you think of when you think of New
Hampshire what I think about is the old
man and Live Free or Die both great
symbols of the great Granite State I
thank the chair and committee members
for their
you no applause
please are there any questions
Madam chair I would just like to point
out that a 13-year-old was able to pull
off a word that the adults in this room
could not actually say so I commend you
sir for uh for your ability to say uh
the V word Vex vexa whatever Vex I can't
even say it
Vexy thank you that that that is
questions apparently not thank you for
your
wheeler thank you chairwoman Maguire
friends and colleagues on the house
executive departments and administration
committee you know that old question are
you smarter than a fifth grader has been
answered and it is no I not smarter than
a fifth grader he did a better job than
I could have on a number of different
testimonies so good job Andrew and I
thank you for being here uh I'm here
today to affirm my support as a
co-sponsor for this piece of legislation
for much of the same reasons that I
brought before you this morning the flag
is poorly designed it's not just a few
individuals that think that it's a
number of people that have said that
based off of the facts that the flag is
poorly designed you couldn't pick it out
from a hall of flags in the middle of
the United States Congress you go to the
United States
Congress good luck finding the flag it's
uh very hard to find amidst all the
others that are blue and have the seal
on top of them there are so many things
in this state that are so distinct and I
think that uh Mr flockton has brought
together and put together a very
well-designed flag that shows what could
come if we opened up uh commissioned up
to to examples
um all you have to do here today is vote
no one's asking you to serve on a
commission or take your time to serve on
a commission and I think it's a little
flippant to say otherwise so so I would
hope that uh this work could be done by
the committee meaning vote to approve
either this or the other commission bill
so that the representatives who want to
serve on the commission and who have uh
pledged that they would spend their time
to serve on this commission could do the
work that you said that you didn't want
to do um with that I'd just like to end
by saying this is an example of good
governance you know the fact that a
13-year-old can come here and speak
before the
legislature that can't happen in every
country and it can't happen in every
state and it's the beauty of New
Hampshire where we can have a young guy
with uh an idea bring that idea to his
representatives and have them bring it
forward to the committee and I think
it's just a great affirmation of the
open process that we have here in New
Hampshire and the Civic engagement that
our citizens have even at the age of 13
if some representative at
13 if you know Jonah wheeler the nerd
that I was if some representative at 13
years old said to me oh you know you
should come come to the legislature and
get involved uh I was I was going to say
I might be here a little earlier but I
was here as early as I could
but I would definitely have been
involved from that age on I would have
felt that the government was listening
to me and so I think it's just thank you
for being so respectful to Mr flockton
and to have him come here today and
congratulations to representative Dunn
for being a good representative that
listens to his constituents so thank you
madam chair I would hope that you vote
to approve this legislation and the
other one the commit Commission because
there are Representatives that are
willing to do the work that you said
that you weren't and are willing to do
that commission to get it done so thank
you very much for those of you that were
respectful and looked diligently at uh
Mr flockton as he testified because it
takes a lot for a 13-year-old to come
here and testify and it means a lot for
him to have adults with the stature that
you have look at him in the eye with
respect and listen to him while he
testified here today so thank you so
much Madam
chairman actually I would have to than
thank you and Miss and representative D
and Mr flockton because I had I believe
five fourth grade classes come visiting
the state house this fall and I told all
of them about this bill and invited them
to read it and testify because I felt
that your average fourth grade class
would be able to give a reasonable
comment on this bill it's much easier
than talking about pensions for example
that's right come to the pension
subcommittee you
know no their eyes glazed over before I
finish the word thank you very much
Madam chair members of the House Edna
committee
other no doesn't look like any questions
Linda
Kelly hi my name is Linda Kelly I am
Andrew flockton mom um I'm speaking in
support of HB 176 to change the St state
flag um Andrew's decision to try to
change the state flag and his subsequent
designs as a result of extensive
research as well as getting people's
opinions he is a ex theologist and
member of Nava and has also followed the
processes of changing the Minnesota and
Utah state flags he's truly driven in
his efforts and personally
inspiring I agree that New Hampshire
definitely needs to replace the current
state flag and replace it with something
that truly represents our uniqueness
what better way than with two instantly
recognizable New Hampshire
symbols um and also to add um
one of the only real issues um seems to
be
ambivalence but a good flag could also
bring in dorus
money I thank um Madam chairwoman and
the committee for their time and
consideration of Andrew's
Bell thank you are there any questions I
don't see any so very good thank you is
there anyone else who wishes to testify
all right seeing none I will close the
public
220 good
God all
right5
is we we have some time before the next
I'm back in 10 minutes yes we'll take a
uh
e
minutes well we can't stop time be done
in the chamber so that's right we can't
we have to deal with it all right
so on there entering executive session
motion in that case I will move in
expedient to legislate I'll
second all right and my comment is not
to say that we don't like this flag
design but that we are not or at least I
am not convinced we need to make a
change we have a commission that will be
setting up the process to make a change
if it is
necessary and this design can C
certainly be considered by that
commission it's a valid submission it
meets the requirements but I think
there's enough
concern about the changing the flag at
all and also about the qualifications of
this committee to judge the quality of a
flag um that I'm recommending in itl
represent gr thank you madam chair I'm
particularly um concerned about our
ability to approve a flag
design because um it's it's one and we
don't know what other
potential um designs we could have and I
even though a lot of people may think
our flag is boring I particularly like
our flag and I don't see why we need to
change it so maybe I mean the minority
but um I'd like the commission that was
discussed earlier to establish a process
and establish one where everyone that is
involved or wants to look at Finance the
flag designs or want to submit a flag
design can do
so representative Tio I I would agree
with you chair one MC McGuire in that I
think that um we should explore other
designs rather than than just one I
think this would be a great one to
submit for the commission to consider
but my other issue is just with the
statutory language that we have in front
of us right now there's it's not very
specific in the dimensions of certain
aspects of the flag and for that reason
it could be hard to reproduce I mean if
we want to talk about biological history
um when the American flag was first
passed with the original flag code no
one really knew exactly how to design it
so you look back and you see all these
old old American flags that look wildly
inconsistent from each other so my fear
is that without some clear statutory
language a similar thing could happen
where you have 50 different vendors
probably selling to tourists who have
wildly different New Hampshire state
flags I think we need something that is
um able to be consistently replicated
and that needs to be reflected in the
statute thank you that's interesting
representative
CCH I guess I'm out of Step once again
um I am not I to the extent that I can I
will never vote for anything that's got
the Old Man of the Mountain on it it's a
pile of rocks it has nothing to do with
personal Integrity value worth anything
that represents real value of car of
character uh if you want to have
something on the flag That's Unique
Mount Washington the highest wind ever
recorded the highest peak east of the
Mississippi um I guess I could go along
with that but it isn't anything to do
with this flag it's just it's been gone
since 2003 it never represented anything
to me again I dare guess I'm out of Step
but that's how I feel okay
representative Lam uh thank you madam
chair and I I do want to thank Mr
flockton for coming up with this design
and bringing it Forward I really
appreciate that um that said when I was
his age I lived in California with that
flag that's the most recognizable state
flag with a bear that you can no longer
find in the state um I actually was very
happy when I moved to New Hampshire that
we had what I considered such a
dignified flag with the seal on the on
the bed sheet of blue and while there's
people who oppose it I actually like it
and uh it's it's an issue of me liking
the current flag uh more than anything
else uh and so I think that's why it's
great that we'll be moving towards a
commission where we can figure out if
the people do want to replace the flag
or not but my vote is I like the current
flag flag and I appreciate the work that
uh Mr flockton put into this um it's
just a design difference so thank you
anyone
else I'd like to mention that in some
things in life boring is good and I'm
not sure if flags are one of them but it
might well be the case any other
comments no I just like to thank that
you pointed out once again that you are
an
engineer yes thank you representative
Pearson my AR my artist judgment is not
to be relied
on and that's another another good
reason to not vote for this in this
committee because as we found out today
it's just chalk full of Engineers and
our our design artistic design judgment
is suspect to say the
least anyone
else all right seeing none the motion is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
one 76 and the clerk can call the
role Vice chair Lon yes clerk votes yes
representative Pearson looking forward
to seeing it in the commission
yes uh representative
Bailey
no representative Sheen
no uh representative
sers yes representative slaty yes yes
representative
yes representative
Dary
yes representative Howard yes
representative Tes
yes representative L yes the chair yes
okay
um see what do we have here uh 16
12 122
122 okay the motion passes
12-2 is there any objection to
consent okay seeing none we'll put this
on Con on
consent
and we will deal with the other issue of
the flag after we get representative
Pearson's um
Amendment Mr um Mr Howard is is going to
be handling the paperwork on that as as
a co-sponsor it was it's better better
op that would be the Optics would be
better yes thank you representative
Howard we have five minutes all right I
would while we are in executive session
I have an amendment to House Bill
598 which is a study
committee to look at the data gathered
by the state
based on comments from the
committee I've amended it to call for
four members of the House rather than
three at least one being a member of the
Senate and then to add to the duties of
the committee to protect personal
identifiable information because there's
um uh state government so I'm
moving Amendment
0310 to House Bill
okay
and as I was saying in the introduction
this fixes some of the concerns we had
with the basic Bill and and
um but it still includes the chart that
a a committee to act look at the data
because we have a very great deal of
data that in many cases we find is not
totally accessible to other departments
or to the public and it ought to be so
um representative l uh thank you madam
chair I I think that this is very very
important to look at this data I think
that being able to have it in a
consistent um evalu consistent format
will be good and um previously serving
on the Health and Human Services
committee we dealt with some of the data
needs and some of the data information
and making sure that we're prioritizing
um protecting personally identifiable
information is consistent with what's
been done through other parts of the
state with it and data and I think that
it's a very good move um and so I
support this amendment in the Bill okay
any representative
Vera thank you I was the one who brought
up the objection to the First Amendment
so I appreciate having my concerns
addressed in the amendment I'll be
supporting it however I do want to say
that it says with at least one member of
the minority party I would have felt
more comfortable with two it says at
least one at least one so you could
technically put one um but I'll take the
amendment and I appreciate the
um personal data also considered so I'll
support the amendment I thank the chair
for bringing forth the
amendment thank you yes I didn't want to
say to mostly because I wanted to make
sure that the members were knew
something about data and how to use it
and I don't know who is there I know
there are members of both parties so if
we can
get I mean if if it turns out we get
three qualified Democrats that want to
serve on this commission I'm not going
to argue with it I don't think this
all R
ferson uh I got a question in reference
to this the expiration date of this
committee did I
help me out if I missed it
um because we have a report
requirement yes the there is a
preliminary report this November a final
one next November this is not a statute
this is in chapter law and I have been
assured that once the final report is in
okay much as I hate chap law that is in
fact a convenience in this
case anyone
else all right in that case the motion
is to adopt Amendment
0310 to House Bill 598 and the clerk can
call the
role Vice chair L yes clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative Bailey I representative
Sheen yes representative sers yes
representative yes representative
TBO
yes representative
groden sorry
yes representative dargy yes
yeses yes representative long yes and
the chair yes well looks like U 14
nothing
okay in that case I'll move off to pass
with Amendment on House Bill
second nothing left to
say
representative so I have to
um I was encouraged when I saw the bill
itself but
I'm not going to be supporting the bill
as amended it has nothing to do with the
amendment it has more with the testimony
that was presented to our committee
which bothers me
significantly
that um the sponsor
testimony was strictly discussing
DCF and although it says all branches of
government and I have
all confidence that that it could be all
branches of
government I still have this concern
that it will not be so therefore that's
my reason for not supporting the bill
and I apologize and I feel very badly
about it but I can't I can't do it sorry
okay representative Leon uh thank you
madam chair and uh thank you for
expressing that representative groda uh
given the town where the prime sponsor
represents and given some of the termout
that happened during special committee
that I chaired with DCF and somebody
else from his town I understand why
concerns over data with DCF would be
front of mind for him however I don't
believe that this bill deals with DC is
intended to specifically deal with DCF I
believe that
given given the amount of attention and
time that we all spent on this and the
lack of data and some of the
contentiousness around it that was an
example given by the prime sponsor
simply because it something that we
lived so often and is a good example of
how clearer data can help us come to
better legislative priorities but I do
not believe that this is at all targeted
to DCF or any division because this is a
matter of making sure that we have
transparency in that information which
we have so that we can make good choices
um I believe that his choice of dcwf as
an example was simply an example and was
simply brought because of our
experiences and not intended as a
singling out
okay anyone else yeah I'd have to agree
that HHS does have a great deal of data
but even on a different Bill we are
saying doesn't the prescription drug
affordability board use data from the
Department of Insurance well it's not
quite in the right format but they it's
the same data and I know that the
department of safety has a great deal of
data on a lot of things Dees has even
more more
so I think just looking around at what
data is
available and like they say to look at
the formats and see you know are we
doing the the smart thing is um is the
intent of this commission um it I
definitely think that as written it
can't proper it can't really be
interpreted as a witch hunt on
DCF um but it would depend on who on the
commission and I can't V for it
representative BR yes thank you um I
appreciate representative Leon and chair
McGuire's comments and I hope
that you can show me wrong I'm not
saying that this is a Witch Hunt DCF but
it could be it could be an investigation
of something else and you're right it
all depends on who's assigned to the
committee and I guess that's something
I'm just going to have to live with and
you know um
okay thank you I appreciate both of you
sharing your thoughts okay any other
questions comments
concerns Lam uh thank you madam chair um
I do want to highlight with bringing up
the prescription drug affordability
board one of the reasons to have the
board is because the data sharing isn't
really there between the department of
insurance and others so having a better
understanding of the sources of data and
potentially how to share them in a
responsible way would save a lot of
money and save a lot of redundancies
throughout the government and therefore
I think that this is a very important
else okay in that case the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment and the
clerk can call the
role chair Leon yes clerk yes
representative
Pearson yes represent Bailey I
representative Shen yes representative
sers yes representative
yes representative TBO yes
Representative groa no
representative uh
dargy yes representative
Howard
no representative
Ares yes representative long yes the
chair
yes I
motion passes 12 to2 is there an
objection to consent no okay all right
we'll uh for what it's worth I mentioned
two things I have yet to failed to call
the chair oh congratulations rookie
mistake of mine many times you're not
the only one every clerk does it the
other thing is we've exct 19 bills for
anybody's County thank you
hey Madam chair just for uh our
own recordkeeping if you will how many
more bills do we have to hold hearings
on roughly we
have I just today scheduled three for
the 19th two fairly short ones and a
major one and then there I think there
are either two or three which will be
held on the the 5th and that should be
that should be it we're we've been
light good all right and I will go
attempt to explain why I voted for a
study
committee all right
um representative tibo
you're I'll open the public hearing on
House Bill 252 and call Representative
Tio
thank you madam chair fellow members of
the committee uh I'm here to encourage
you to vote a to pass on HP 252 to
declare January 18th as Daniel Webster
day um we've had a lot of talk about um
patriotism and state symbols today and I
think that Daniel Webster is a very
important symbol of the State of New
Hampshire not just within the state but
as we represent ourselves outside of the
state um the but first I would like to
talk about what this bill is not because
I've read a lot of um or some of the
opposition comments on on the online for
and some people seem to think that this
is a day off for workers it is not this
is a um State commemoration um simply
remembering the history of Daniel
Webster um as an important figure in New
Hampshire history um and the reason I
brought this forward is because I spoke
to a lot of school administrators and
teachers who look for more ways to
engage students with New Hampshire
history and they find that these sorts
of State commemorations like what would
be Daniel Webster day like John Stark
day like Constitution Day these are ways
to provide excuses to take some time and
talk about the significance of New
Hampshire history and the reason I
brought forward Daniel Webster day is
because we have uh a day for General
John Stark who is significant in his
contributions to the re Revolutionary
War well Webster is just as significant
to the um post-war period as America
tries to Define itself on the world
stage particularly leading up to the
Civil War in the antibellum period um
but I don't really want to focus on his
oration because that's something I would
hope a lot of people are aware of I kind
of want to focus on um something that
people might not know and that's sort of
his upbringing uh his life story is um
the embodiment of the American dream he
was born in Salsbury now Franklin and um
he was expected not to survive he was a
very sickly baby um born to poor um
farming parents on what was then the
frontier and um despite the odds he
survived and he be um while he couldn't
work on the farm like his brothers and
sisters he did become an Avid Reader he
memorized um large chunks of the Bible
to the point where when they had
competitions to see who could read the
most of the Bible his teachers actually
had to tell him to stop because they um
he he just kept going and going he
memorized the Constitution as a young
boy there's a portrait of him doing so
in the New Hampshire Senate and he's
really an embodiment of it what it means
to be well read and well educated as a
child especially in the ways of civics
and he later became one of the stest
Defenders of the constitution in the
United States Senate um uh he went he
also went to Dartmouth at age 15 despite
his parents meager finances um they
sacrificed everything they could to make
sure that he got the education that he
needed and deserved um and he ended up
being incredibly successful despite all
of the challenges that laid in his way
um and in addition to that um his
influence is still felt into the modern
day um he started the United States
Senate page program when he was um in
the Senate representing the state of
Massachusetts and to this day um Pages
um know about him they love him and even
though I wasn't not a Paige myself so
many of them came to me and said how
meaningful this is to them they live in
a building called Webster Hall in fact
and they have a little Shrine in their
in their building to to Daniel Webster
because this program has really changed
their lives it gives them an opportunity
to work on the senate floor to learn
about our government in a wholly unique
way and I think that's a really powerful
Legacy of New Hampshire outside of our
state um and I understand that there may
be concerns about creating new state
observes because they won't be
recognized people won't know about them
but I think this will be different I've
talked to administrators both within my
district and without and as well as
teachers and they really want things
like this so they can have opportunities
to teach teach um their kids about what
makes New Hampshire exceptional and um
so this provides them that
opportunity um in addition to this I
also included the provision to have the
um second reply to hanne speech which is
considered one of the greatest pieces of
oration in American history um to be
read each year it's optional it's just
enabling legislation um um just so it's
very similar to how other bodies
including Congress would read the
Constitution or the Declaration on the
respective anniversaries of those
documents just we don't do that because
we're not in session for those
anniversaries so in addition to this um
the mayor of Franklin as well as um um
representatives of Dartmouth College and
historical societies have reached out to
me and expressed their support for this
legislation because they really want to
see um Websters celebrated and
remembered in a way like this and
looking back at the Historical records
there are many instances of celebrations
of um Webster's both birthday and
anniversary of his graduation from
Dartmouth um throughout the state from
Franklin and Salsbury to Handover to at
the state level so this is not something
that's without precedent it just puts it
into State Statute and allow us for it
to be more publicly aware for schools to
be able to work on so with that um I'll
be open to questions but I really
encourage you to pass HB 252 thank you
okay representa
salers thank you madam chair um could
you tell me do you know how many
proclamations the governor does each
year I'm aware there's quite a few um
this will be um uh this so this is DD
and there have been some that are
repealed as well so there are quite a
few but this would be um one that isn't
so much about the proclamation and more
about giving an opportunity for New
schools other questions represent Lam uh
thank you madam chair would this require
this to be taught in the schools no
there's no requirement here it just
provides the opportunity it gives them a
day to just discuss it and um hopefully
promote it no the only person who is
mandated by it is the governor or
actually his
staff any other
questions all right thank you very much
thank you guys very
much is there anyone else who wishes to
252 all right seeing none I will close
subes yes all
right let's go into executive session
and deal with some of the bills that
have been coming out of the
subcommittees uh representative Leon you
have a uh you have one um yes Madam
chair um House Bill 637 um was in the
pension subcommittee last week and it
was recommended itl 3 to2 and so I would
move and expediate to legislate on House
Bill
637 637 all right uh thank you would you
remind us of the titles for those of us
whose memories are in incorrect yes um
it is relative to the reduction in the
calculation of State retirement
annuities at age 65 for certain group
one retirement system members um that's
the one where it was brought to us as an
oversight from um previous introduced as
oversight from previous legislation okay
is there a second
sorry who said Thank you thank
you all right you and you had you were
saying uh yes we discussed this in our
sellers sellers um we discussed this in
our subcommittee and we looked at the
legislative history of this bill um of
the bill that this seeks to correct um
in the Senate they heard a bill in order
to provide in order to match up the
change in retirement payments with the
actual full Social Security retirement
age as opposed to 65 which had been in
the statutes when it was introduced in
January 18th of 2023 in the Senate it
was highlighted at that point that it
would not include anybody who retired
prior to the bill being enacted um at
that point Senate Edna chose not to
amend the bill to um to extend this to
people who retired before the effective
date um it then went to Senate Finance
where they did not choose to extend this
to th to those who retired prior to the
effective date um even though that was
raised in Senate Finance then this was
added to the budget by the Senate and at
that point they also did not choose to
include those people who retired prior
to the enactment of the budget it was
not an oversight it was a conscious
Choice by the Senate not to include them
on this bill that had on on the original
bill which had a pretty significant
fiscal note there was discussion in the
committee that it's not our job to deal
with money
because this goes to finance but this is
actually not a second committee bill
this bill if we were to approve it now
would move forward and would not go to
finance because there was not a fiscal
note on it so we don't even know how
large of a financial impact this would
have so given that we don't understand
how large it would be it would not go to
fiscal and it was a conscious choice on
the part of the Senate to not include
the people who had retired prior to the
enactment I believe that it's
appropriate to to um vote an expedient
to legislate on this
salar nothing to add okay thank you
representative Howard thank you madam
chair so a while back there was a
reduction in calculation for State uh
retirement annuities for group two
retires and this is just trying to make
sure that we have the same system
applying to both groups it would
make I'm sorry to interupt to which two
groups group one and group two I I I may
have this is again I'm trying to
remember from the subcommittee but
because I don't have my notes but there
was an explanation provided by uh one of
uh the members who showed up talking
about how this was trying to uh fix a
gap that we had where there was a change
made to one of the other groups and not
provided to the other so this is just
trying to make sure that we have
equality in the policy that we are
providing and while there is going to be
an increase in the fiscal note there was
a fiscal note included at at the end of
the bill uh this is still something that
should be considered by Finance because
at least in terms of a policy
perspective I think that we should be
making sure that we are providing uh a
quality across the board thank you
okay I'd like to comment on that the
change oh since the
80s
um group one has had a reduction in
their pension at the age of 65 which
was to correspond with their retirement
age for Social
Security the bill that the Senate dealt
with two years ago moved it from age 65
to the Social Security full retirement
age and it was that was change that was
implemented as of the date of effective
effectivity
these the the Gap is between the people
who retired before that bill was
effective and were still under
65 so it's not that things changed for
them it's that things did not change
they had been dealing with this change
in
retirement and change in pension since
the
80s and when they retired they knew what
was going to
happen so they were not and the and the
Senate apparently deliberately decided
not to backdate the effectivity to
people who
were retired but not under age but not
over age 65 at the time and uh it it's
not like any of the changes made to
group two where things changed after
they were hired this is that a change
was not
clear
any other comments questions
R thank you um first of
all the fiscal note for this bill
was going to be delivered to the house
Clerk and I have to tell you that I miss
Marty Carlin and I'm sure the New
Hampshire retirement system ises him too
however the fact that there's an impact
a financial impact on this bill does not
mean that it's not going to finance so
it will go to finance I have no doubt
about that it's not an early Bill okay
well it has an FN on it thank you yes so
the other
um the other uh point that I want to
make is that the way this was originally
written did not include this
Loop and so what this bill's trying to
do is include this group and bring them
in line with group two group one was
never in line with them on this
particular
issue group two this has nothing to do
with group two
well that's what was given in the
testimony that's what I have written
down no it doesn't have anything to do
with group two it's only group one that
this was some sort of a clude that the
legislature in the 80s came up with when
they were disentangling the P the group
one pensions from Social Security and
the history
is murky to say the least right has
nothing to do with group two so I'm I
mean I support the itl but I support the
itl
for reasons
that um I think I don't I don't want to
change the retirement system anymore
than it's already changed I want to
leave it the way it is let things we've
made a lot of changes to it I just would
like things to stay the same for a while
um just to see where we are especially
in a year like this one so I support the
itl thank you that's very clear any
other comment
onitech I was around when we when this
murkiness started um and there was never
a Clear Connection even though the dates
were 65 and convenient or lent
themselves to comparison with Social
Security it was never established that
that was the reason I've never liked
it I will vote against itl and maybe
when
Finance persuades me otherwise in light
of this year but it just never felt
right to me ever so oh
interesting represent lamb uh thank you
madam chair this bill is not marked as
an early bill this is due out of
committee March March 20th which means
that it is not going to finance so this
we are the final statement in the house
we do it soon enough we might be able to
get it to finance but anyway if it if it
if we if we pass it I'm going to
strongly recommend that it does go to
finance because it has a fiscal note
significant any other comments questions
how much time
over thank
you okay no further comments all
right the motion is in exped to
legislate on House Bill 637 and the
clerk can call the RO Vice chair Lon yes
clerk coures no representative
Pearson yes representative Bailey hi
representative Sheen yes representative
sers yes representative SL yes
representative tibo yes representative
groa yes yes representative dargy
no uh representative D no representative
L
yes and the chair
yes okay three against and 11 for I got
12 well it's we got 14 here don't
we 11 and three add up to 14 one two
three four five six seven8 9 10 11 it's
113 okay 11 113
okay thank you I oh that's right it's 11
to3 fine the motion passes
11-3 is
there do you wish to write a Minority
Report anyone representive Howard will
write a Minority Report thank you madam
chair okay and that will therefore then
not be that will then be on the regular
calendar
EXA represent Shane you have a
suggestion yes um our subcommittee would
like to recommend adopting an amendment
that we um created for HB 428 I have
committee okay repres Shan moves House
Bill 428 with Amendment and he's giving
okay and this I believe is the municipal
amendments to the building code correct
yes so um may I speak to the amendment
Madam chair please
speak um the amendment
um was approved by the prime sponsor as
well as looked over um and drafted with
the help of Phil Sherman um on the
building uh code review board the
amendment replaces all of the existing
Bill language without changing the
intent of the underlying
Bill the amendment allows for
administrative amendments related to
statutory Authority and allows for
multiple ways the code could be
implemented in
municipalities the amendment also
performs some bookkeeping moving
building code related sections now in
the land use and City Grant of powers
chapters into RSA 155a where they should
be placed um and it corrects conflicting
terminology a cross reference error with
within the current statutes but still
maintains the current building code
review board confirmation process for
necessary administrative
ordinances um the amendment also removes
several references to the state fire
code in order that they may re be
relocated to um um a more appropriately
appropriate place and I believe that
that's being done through a Senate
bill so um with that the the
subcommittee recommends
passing the amendment and then also
amendment okay represent
Lam thank you I think she said more than
I could on
this you had a question I do I just want
to make sure that so I'm reading on page
20 any provision of the State Building
Code that conflicts with existing local
ordinances regulations policies
practices or procedures regarding the
appointment removal or duties of
Municipal Employees and organization of
Municipal departments shall not
apply provided that the ordinances
regulations policies and practices or
procedures do not prevent effective
enforcement of the State Building Code
so I just want to make sure what they're
saying saying is that Municipal
Department's Personnel cannot interfere
saying that didn't come up uh when we
were discussing it but I would think
that that's what it says I'm not an
expert on the that particular
section but it didn't come out um in
anything that uh the building codes um
review board or anything when he was
amendment represent um thank you madam
chair and thank you representative groda
for highlighting that if I were to take
out part of it it reads any provision of
the State Building Code that conflicts
shall not apply so I'm curious if this
means that it's actually instead of
having the State Building Code be the
dominant um choice if this language
would actually lead to the Municipal I
don't understand I'm just trying to make
sure that I understand the language of
it because to me if I were to take out
everything within that Clause that says
with the existing local ordinances I'm
just trying to understand exactly what
that phrase does for
us I'm not quite
sure it might be that the building code
talks about
inspectors and each town can have
appoint its code inspectors however it
wish
and doesn't need anybody's approval they
may not call them the the code
enforcement
whatever
is well that's the way I'm reading this
I'm reading this that the what they're
saying that any provisions of the State
Building
Code that relate to regulations policies
and practices or procedures regarding
the appointment removal or duties of the
Municipal Employees so originally I
think it might have been not in
here and so that's what they mean by
administrative
amendments however my concern still is
with line
23-31 which says that the building code
shall be effective in all Municipal
municipalities as defined by blah blah
blah in the state without further
modification except as permitted by this
section and shall be enforced as
provided by
155a col SEO not withstanding any other
provision of the law no local
legislative body shall Ena or enforce
any ordinance adopt or enforce any
rule except as otherwise permitted by
the section so are they saying that this
that 155 d a as defined in RSA
672 allows municipalities
to um present amendments for approval is
this I just want to be sure that
municipalities who need relief from the
building code for for example in my area
we have Wetlands everywhere so we need
building Cod modifications for septic
systems which is what we have now
through
the that was gone that was gone through
the amendment process um the proper
Amendment processes so are we saying
that that process is still there albe it
smaller or are we saying that that
process is gone forever and it might be
that we just need to take obviously no
and somebody's saying I it it says
except as otherwise permitted by this
section and this section talks about
when you can make amendments which is
it's back on page two I think
okay the section refer to the whole
thing yes yeah this is a section okay
okay it is it is more limited than
intent represent de
re so um I'd love to give this a really
close read um I I'm not comfortable
voting on this today myself I'll just
put that out there and I want to run
this by um my own um building department
in my town to see how this would apply I
talked a little bit about us having in
my community having higher standards in
terms of free board and I want to make
sure that as currently as this has been
amended that we can still have those
higher
standards and I the way that I on my
scanning of this I I'm not 100% sure
that that's the case okay I think this
is is a little bit much for us to get it
once so if if there's no objection we'll
recess and come back to this later thank
you so much any objections okay thank
you we will study this a bit
more all
else Madam sherff it's yes um if it's
proper I'd like to move out to pass on
if we can if you'd like to take it up
later okay representative tibo since
we're still in executive session moves
second
Howard okay um anything um I mean other
than my testimony I would just say this
bill does nothing but um um recognize
someone who's very important to New
Hampshire history as we've all
established it's a very important thing
to celebrate and it helps um encourage
teachers um in schools to teach their
kids about a very important figure so I
would encourage an not to pass a motion
on this Bill thank you okay
representative Howard do you to
speak yeah uh thank you madam chair uh I
want to agree with representative tbo's
comments uh I think that this uh being a
Kim rber holiday uh allows us to really
kind of uh push uh an opportunity for
students to to learn about New Hampshire
history and a real New Hampshire icon
thank
you anyone else represents s thank you
madam chair I'm going to vote against
this because it it only says here it
says uh line nine it says the schools
are encouraged it doesn't say they have
to they shall so it's just I don't know
I just look at this as a another thing
for the governor to do and maybe the
schools will do it maybe they
Pearson in uh three terms in this
committee we've had all kinds of
fun days come before us
and stuff that you just wow but in this
this
case I think this is this is a little
different uh you know in the sense
that we're looking at a a very
specific person a very specific framer
of this
country
um and it's not one of these blanket
things where we're you know looking at
different flavors of ice cream or
something for the day
so um as far as the line nine the
encouraging part uh we run into problems
when we start
mandating curriculum which is
really not the purview it's really the
Department of Education so it's not even
this committee that would be mandating
curriculum
um
and the encouraging language is
consistent with other things so
I I I actually would be I would have
been object objecting to this if it had
been a mandate um simply because it it
just wouldn't have been appropriate for
this committee to set educational policy
but
the the fact that the
students today
when have no idea who Alan Shepard is
who have no they barely know who Chris
mall is they barely know there there's
too many things that that that have
shaped the state and too many folks that
have been involved in that that that
seem to just be lost forever and Daniel
Webster is certainly worthy of of um
recognition
and and highlighting in in a educational
sense and a historical review so so I'm
going to go I'm going to go off my
normal script with these kind of days
represent of
sellers thank you madam chair I I
suppose the other reason I I'm objecting
to this is I kids don't even know how to
read and write I mean we have a huge
failure rate and no one's addressing it
and we keep throwing money at it and now
we got to throw an encouraging thing
that they should be doing on January
18th for historical and and good reason
I'm not saying it's bad but I'm saying
we have a big problem with reading and
writing and we need to square that away
before we start throwing something else
at the kids representative Howard thank
you madam chair I I think that when
we're talking about history there is a
great opportunity for students to engage
in reading and writing because there is
a lot of reading that is done with
history I'm a history major right now at
the University of New Hampshire I'm I've
got one semester left and it's pretty
much a majority of our work is just
reading through old documents and then
writing an analysis of those documents
if we're talking about trying to educate
our kids about reading and writing I
don't really see anything else better
than saying read about a New Hampshire
historical figure that has been
extremely influential in the state and
you I'd like to say that I agree with
representative sellers that we shouldn't
be telling the teachers of the state to
remember Daniel Webster because they
know as well as we we do or probably a
whole lot better how important he was
and what he what his influence was on
the state and in its history um they're
the expert I'm not going to tell them
how to um come or when to commemorate
Daniel Webster and
I'm strongly opposed to putting this
sort of thing into statute because once
it happens the supporters go away they
have no memory of it it's the governor
sends out an announcement and it it
fades and I'm against creating more days
that are nice they're always of somebody
important and interesting
but they don't do
anything representative lamb um thank
you madam chair I am a new member on the
commission on Holocaust and genocide
education and U while I haven't been
part of that Comm commission for long
one of the big challenges they're facing
is that even though that is in the
compulsory education um not many people
understand how to teach that we have the
Cohen Institute which provides
information on how to do this but
looking through some of the surveys
about what is actually taught in our
schools it's unclear whether the
teachers and whether the districts even
know how to teach Holocaust and genocide
education and while I appreciate the
interest in wanting to make sure that
people know and honor Daniel Webster
when we have trouble having consistency
in teaching about the Holocaust and
genocide I'm also concerned that adding
one more thing to that list will um
won't be done in the schools and then
also people will see that it's there and
they'll think that this is already been
handled when it's not I think that I
think that just creating a state holiday
and having the proclamation from the
governor without any sort of materials
or resources to provide to the to the
schools um would allow us to check that
box but not necessarily have that
education and I actually would encourage
encourage you to work on creating some
voluntary information that can be used
to teach people in the classes so that
they can actually understand this and
appreciate it and I'm afraid that if we
pass it now both both will be operating
contrary to sort of what
this the way we've approached all of
these different proclamations in the
past but more importantly people will
think that it's handled and done when
it's not and I think that that would be
more of a shame to have people say that
oh we're already teaching this when it's
not being taught well representative
sler thank you madam chair um I just
wanted to share that the reason I'll be
voting against this I think it's
important to understand uh history and
all its context but I I feel as though
this commemoration might invite
unnecessary um Strife in in
understanding that Daniel Webster was
anti-ab abolitionist and supported the
Fugitive Slave Act um as a commemoration
I think is is probably a little bit far
for the state to go it's important to
remember history it's important that
that individuals um are accountable to
that history but for us to commemorate
an individual who had somewhat of a
mixed past I think is is something that
we ought not put our uh you know invest
any time in thank you okay
representative broa yes I hope I'm the
last speaker I'll be supporting the bill
because he have a mixed pack M Miss
mixed past but his picture is hanging in
in bigger than life in our chamber so
mea I would also point out that he's the
only figure to not only have his statue
in front of two State houses but also in
the US capital and in addition to being
in our chamber he's in the New Hampshire
Senate chamber so there is not a want
for um representation within the state
house it's just about getting that out
to the people and I would absolutely
agree with representative Lon that I
think it'd be great to work with the doe
to try to get those resources out and
maybe that could be an amendment to like
say the Department of Education shall be
directed to um create some materials to
distribute to schools if they um so
choose um I'd be open to something like
that if that would be something the
committee would want or I could work
with them on my own if the bill were to
pass to get those materials
created okay anyone
else well spoken represent scitech why
did we wait 150 years for this if it was
a good idea back then not a bad idea but
it's just another clutter unfortunately
all
righto as I said during my testimony um
while it may not have been in State
Statute this is a celebration that has
been commemorated over the years um by
localities thank
you anyone else proving how necessary
all right
there's the Motions ought to pass CL can
no no uh CH clerk
no uh representative Pearson yes
represent Bailey nay representative Shen
no Representative sers no representa
no representative TBO yes representative
groa
yes representative Dary
yes representative Howard yes
representes
yes representative long yes and the
chair
eight 8 to six
it I ought to pass
some ought to pass
it wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I the motion was ought to
pass and there were
six six in favor yeah I have you
incorrectly
this
77 does someone else wish to make a
different
motion Madam chair representative Howard
I would uh like to move to recess this
bill until we have more members because
this bill is likely going to end up as a
tide vote as
well fine we will recess and revote on
committee
um I think I've had enough so I'm going
you just purp on sellers thank you just
a point of order is that is that a
proper move I I'm just checking the well
the mo the executive session can be
recessed at any time at the moment we
have a a tie vote looking at the people
who voted in in each
position it's not clear that they would
vote one
happen and I think we've had enough for
today so I'm going to close our
executive session we are in in house
session tomorrow next week on the 19th
we have a couple of hearings in the
morning and then an executive session in
the